[Musique]
Thomas Visel, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons ce soir pour une
chaîne internet qui s'appelle Syerview.
Nous sommes en direct. Comment ça va ?
Ça va très bien. Et toi ?
Ça va. Ça va être chaud.
Pourquoi ?
Bonne année.
Ah oui, c'est jusqu'à fin janvier chez
vous ?
Ouais. Ou ouais. Et pourquoi en Suisse ?
C'est jusqu'à quand ?
Nous, on se le dit pas tellement. Non,
je sais pas. Mais je sais qu'il y a une
tradition française où il y a un délai.
31 janvier est en droit de dire bonne
année.
Bon, est-ce que vous ou tu tu peux te
présenter succintement ?
Je m'appelle Thomas Wizel, je suis
humoriste de Lausanne en Suisse puis de
temps en temps je vais en France mais le
moins possible.
Pourquoi le moins possible ? parce que
c'est pas chez moi. Moi je suis mieux
chez moi. Non, c'est j'aime bien la
France mais je suis pas à l'aise à Paris
et donc j'évite un peu.
Bon alors on vous on te reçoit ce soir
parce que la communauté nous a envoyé
une vidéo de toi où tu atomises euh
Nestle. Hm
hm. Euh euh et on a creusé, on a été
voir d'autres atomisations dans avec les
les règles de l'art sur des sujets
relativement complexes et même très
complexes comme la pauvreté,
l'hypercapitalisme,
le technocapitalisme 4.0 et les
journalistes rachitiques.
Ouais.
Dénutri. Non, c'est comment tu avais dit
? Des
mal nutrir. Je croisement. Ouais.
Donc ça nous a intéressé. Donc on va
creuser un peu le truc. Euh comment ça
se passe quand on est humoriste dans au
21e siècle avec des attentats,
des lobbistes un peu partout, des
groupes de pression un peu partout ?
Est-ce que on peut encore à l'heure
actuelle être un salet banque qui met
les sujets chauds sur la table ?
Oui, moi j'ai vraiment l'impression
qu'on peut absolument tout faire. Euh
suisse,
ben moi je le fais en Suisse parce que
je suis en Suisse mais j'ai pas
l'impression qu'il y a davantage de
censure ici. Si je regarde mes confrères
ici en France ou en Belgique ou au
Québec, je trouve qu'on a une marge de
manœuvre.
Enfin, on part de loin parce que les
pionniers du standup aux États-Unis,
c'est dès qu'il disaient un gros mot, la
police venait les chercher sur scène.
Donc c'est maintenant, on a une latitude
qui est quand même nettement plus large.
Après, les gens peuvent répondre et ça
c'est peut-être la nouveauté depuis 10
15 ans, c'est qu'avec les réseaux
sociaux, il y a un droit de réponse qui
est quasi automatique où les gens
peuvent se fédérer, s'organiser, nous
donner une réponse. Et en tant
qu'humoriste, je trouve que c'est
important d'être attentif à ce qu'on
nous répond et soit de de décider que
bah les personnes qui nous répondent
sont des hystériques et qu'ils ont pas
raison, soit de temps en temps de
prendre des critiques constructives.
J'essaie de le faire en tout cas, mais
les lobby dont tu parles, les groupes de
pression, moi je les ressens pas
tellement. Moi, c'est plutôt des cibles
que des gens qui influent sur mon
quotidien. Quo
là, je vais te lire un un bout du papier
de Charlie Hebdo qui dit "Hier, on
disait merde à Dieu à l'armée, à
l'église, à l'État. Aujourd'hui, il faut
prendre il faut apprendre à dire merde
aux associations tyranniques, aux
minorités nombrilistes, aux blogueurs et
blogueuses qui nous tapent sur les
doigts comme les petits maîtres d'école
écritis le directeur de la rédaction
dans son éditorial.
Moi je pense Charlie c'est un point de
vue très particulier parce qu'ils ont
vécu toute cette transition
et ils ont vécu l'avénement des réseaux
sociaux donc ils ont vu la vraie
modification sur leur travail. Moi j'ai
commencé en 2011, il y avait déjà les
réseaux sociaux. Le premier truc que
j'ai fait, c'est de me faire une page
Facebook. Donc je peux pas tellement
comparer avant après, mais c'est sûr que
tu t'es fait kicker, non ? Facebook.
Ouais, mais 24 heures et ça m'a fait
énormément de pub. Donc si on peut me le
refaire, moi je je suis avec kické.
On sait pas trop parce qu'ils disent
pas. Mais en gros chronologiquement,
c'était juste après une chronique sur
l'UDC qui est notre partie d'extrême
droite qui est qu'on a plus le droit
d'appeler extrême droite. Maintenant, on
dit la droite bourgeoise. Euh donc c'est
l'équivalent du ration national en
Suisse. Et j'avais fait une chronique
parce que eux ils ont beaucoup d'argent.
C'est le parti qui a le plus d'argent en
Suisse.
C'est quoi beaucoup ?
Ben on sait pas parce qu'il y a pas de
transparence dans le financement des
partis politiques.
Mais c'est ils ont plus d'argent que les
autres partis parce que à chaque
votation ils et nous on vote souvent en
Suisse.
On va en parler. Ouais, je pense qu'il y
a un peu de jalousie de ce côté-ci, de
la frontière. Ils inondent les gens de
ce qu'on appelle un tout ménage. Donc tu
ouvres ta boîte aux lettres et tu as
genre un journal de
j'ai envie de dire propagande mais en
tout cas qui partage le point de vue de
ce partie-là dans toutes les boîtes aux
lettres sur 15 pages. Et j'avais une
fois décortiqué un de ses journaux à
l'occasion d'une votation, j'avais posté
la chronique et c'est là que j'avais été
mon compte ma page Facebook a été
supprimée. Je pense ça a été signalé en
masse. Je pense qu'un une section locale
de ce parti a dû se mobiliser. On sait
pas qui a signalé en masse mais en gros,
ils ont supprimé mon truc, j'ai signalé
que c'était une erreur et ils l'ont
remis 24 heures après. Mais entre-
tempemps, tous les médias suisses, donc
quatre euh lequel alors ?
Bah c'était le temps, le 24 he, la RTS
et je pense une audio radio privée.
C'est à peu près le paysage médiatique
qu'on a en ce moment.
C'était
fait le le l'écho de cette suppression
censure machin. Donc ça avait beaucoup
fait parler de moi. La chronique qui
était encore en ligne sur YouTube avait
été très vue et après ils ont remis ma
page Facebook. Donc moi j'étais content
quoi. J'ai eu pas d'impact à part
beaucoup de médiatisation mais ça pour
moi c'est des c'est des épiphénomènes.
Mais sinon
je vois pas tellement la censure des
réseaux sociaux. Je la ressens pas.
Parce que ce qu'on peut ressentir, c'est
effectivement de temps en temps une
réponse, de temps en temps des
associations qui nous disent ça, on n
pas aimé, on n pas aimé puis moi je lis
pourquoi des fois ça modifie mon point
de vue, des fois pas. Et puis c'est
simplement un dialogue et je trouve ça
plutôt riche que le monologue des
humoristes ou dans les années 80, tu
allais à la télé, tu faisais une blague
sur les noirs et tu savais jamais
l'impact que ça avait à part que les
gens dans la salle rient peut-être ou
pas mais tandis que maintenant les
personnes qui sont visées peuvent
répondre et ça je vois pas pourquoi
c'est mal.
Donc tu n'es pas fan de Michel Leb ?
Je suis assez peu fan de Michel Leb. Bon
alors question internet, je t'en prends
deux comme ça puis après on va
enchaîner. La première de Céline,
comment les multinationales continuent à
l'inviter dans des meetings sachant
qu'il clashera ses autres ? Et la
deuxième c'est combien il gagne Visel ?
Alors la première, souvent je suis pas
invité par la multinationale en
elle-même. La vidéo de Nesle dont tu
parlais c'est un forum pour les PME.
Vous dites ça aussi en France.
PME
PME on est en France
pardon les PME euh qui éta organisé par
le temps qu'on vient de citer qui est un
journal suisse de qualité. Je dis pas ça
juste parce qu'ils m'ont employé mais
la tribune de Genève qu'est-ce que tu en
penses ? La tribune de Genève, c'est
quasi fusionné avec le 24 heur
maintenant. Puis c'est un journal
généraliste que je suis abonné. Donc
moi, pour moi, il est très bien. Euh et
c'est eux qui organisaient ce forum et
qui invitait à la fois Peter Brabec qui
est le l'ex-président de Nesley et moi.
Donc c'était pas Nesley qui m'invitait
directement. Et souvent c'est comme ça,
c'est jamais le PDG qui m'invite, c'est
soit le petit mec qui s'occupe ou la
nana qui s'occupe de l'événementiel dans
la filiale machin. Donc
c'est qui va perdre son taf ?
Ouais. ou alors elle va dire "Je savais
pas, j'étais pas au courant ou des trucs
comme ça." J'ai pas connaissance de
quelqu'un qui a perdu son taf après
m'avoir programmé. Mais souvent c'est
des gens qui ont justement envie
d'entendre l'autre point de vue et dans
les multinationales, il y a plein de
gens qui sont pas lobotomisés et qui ont
besoin d'un job et de gagner leur vie et
qui sont contre certains des agissements
de leur boîte. Donc euh pour moi, il y a
pas tout qui est acheté. Donc c'est je
pense c'est pour ça que je continué à
être invité parce qu'il y a des gens qui
aiment bien ce que je fais et que c'est
rarement le grand patron qui valide le
truc. Mais il y a plein d'endroits qui
m'invitent plus. Même les clubs de
sport, il y en a plein qui osent plus
m'inviter. Donc
quel
ceux de ma ville le FC Lausanne là,
le Lausanne Sport et le Lausanne Hockey
Club. C'est deux clubs où j'ai fait une
fois et puis j'ai plus été invité. Non,
Laanne Sport, j'ai fait deux fois mais
je sais pas pourquoi c'est des clubs qui
m'invitent plus mais c'est leur droit.
Moi je revendique pas le fait de devoir
m'inviter. Mais donc pour répondre à la
question de Céline, parfois on arrête de
m'inviter mais le club d'à côté va
m'inviter, l'entreprise d'à côté va
m'inviter. Donc j'ai j'ai du travail. Et
combien je gagne ? Bah ça dépend. Si je
travaille pas, je gagne pas. Moi je suis
pas, il y a pas de statut d'intermittent
en Suisse, donc je suis vraiment payé au
cachet. Et ces soirées privées comme on
appelle ça sont bien payées. Donc ça
dépend de combien j'en fais.
C'est quoi bien ? Moi, je suis entre 7
et 10000 francs suisse en fonction bah
c'est un
divisé par 1,2 donc entre je sais pas 6
et 8000 6 et 9000 € et ça ça dépend de
combien de temps je dois être sur scène,
combien je dois personnaliser et cetera
et puis sur l'année ben on est entre 100
et 200000 donc je gagne bien ma vie.
Alors, il faut adapter au niveau de vie
en Suisse où tout est à peu près quatre
fois plus cher, les loyers, la bouffe,
tout ça. Euh, on dit que le SMIC suisse
qui n'existe pas parce minimum, mais le
salaire considéré comme limite bas en
Suisse, c'est 3500 4000 francs, donc euh
3000 3500 €. Donc, je gagne beaucoup
mieux ma vie que ça et je suis très
chanceux.
Mais tu as pas fait que ça avant, tu
étais comptable ou pas longtemps parce
que moi j'ai commencé à faire des
blagues en 2011 et j'ai eu mon diplôme
en 2010. Donc j'ai bossé un peu comme
comptable à temps partiel pour une boîte
qui a fait faillite euh mais pas pas à
cause de moi, enfin du moins je le crois
et euh et ça n'a jamais été une grande
passion mais j'étais pas encore prêt à
me lancer totalement et puis assez
rapidement j'ai fait que de l'humour.
Alors au début je gagnais 500 balles par
mois et puis j'étais sur mes économies
puis assez rapidement j'ai trouvé du
job.
Qu'est-ce que ça fait quand on est de
formation de comptable suisse de son
état qu'on va tailler des croupières
à l'évasion fiscale, au grands patron ?
Toi, en tant que suisse, est-ce que la
politique de ton état sur l'évasion
fiscale, le secret bancaire, le
démarchage de boîte et je t'en passe,
c'est des meilleurs, comment c'est perçu
déjà pour toi et comment s'est perçu
auprès de ton entourage ? Comment s'est
perçu chez les Suisses ?
C'est assez c'est assez particulier
parce que je pense si tu poses la
question à des suisses, il y en a pas
beaucoup qui vont dire "On est pour le
secret bancaire, on est pour accueillir
des fonds, des errances, pour accueillir
des dictateurs." On a beaucoup de
dictateurs à Genève et cetera et on est
pour fermer les yeux sur la provenance
de l'argent. Je pense que la plupart
sont contre,
mais ça se reflète pas forcément dans
les votes qu'on a et ils sont pas
forcément de façon militante contre,
c'est-à-dire qu'on s'en fout un peu et
on est un peu conscient quand même. Je
pense qu'on a prospéré.
notamment sang
sur un peu du sang. Bah derrière toute
grande fortune se cache un crime mais je
pense que la fortune de la Suisse est de
loin pas une exception. Et le fait aussi
qu'on a on nit pas dû se reconstruire
après la guerre parce qu'on a été très
modérément détruit. Je crois que Genève
s'est fait bombarder parce qu'ils ont
confondu avec Gen donc ils ont largué
les bombes sur Genova au lieu de Genoa.
Mais sinon il y a quasi aucun truc qui
avait à reconstruire les années 40 et on
avait plein de cash à disposition parce
que les juifs étaient pas revenus
chercher l'argent qu'ils avaient mis
chez nous. Du coup, c'est là que la
Suisse a un peu pris son envol. Donc ça,
on est conscient de ça. Donc il y a je
pense que la Suisse est moins cliché que
ce qu'on imagine dans le sens où on
n'est pas tous en train de dire que il
faut avoir tout l'argent des riches chez
nous. Ça nous énerve un peu ce cliché
chez les Français, c'est le fromage, le
chocolat et l'argent des riches. La
Suisse. Donc c'est
Non, non, il y a il y a d'autres
perceptions. Je vais qui n'engagent que
c'est les Suisses à la base, c'est un
peu comme les Saoudiens. À la base,
c'était des cutéreux.
Ouais. et et ils ont eu plein de pognons
un coup mais ça reste quand même des
cutéreux.
C'est c'est drôle parce qu' il y a
Ouais, il y a un peu le double cliché,
on est des paysans, on parle lentement,
vous faites l'accent qui n'existe pas
vraiment parce que c'est un espèce de
vous fait essayer de mélanger un peu
tous les accents puis ça ressemble un
peu à rien mais en même temps on est
super riche et puis on est snob et
cetera. Donc c'est un peu Ouais. Deux
visions bizarres qui cohabitent, mais je
crois que la perception des Suisses,
elle est majoritairement
assez content quand il y a l'évolution
au niveau bancaire, ce qui est le cas
ces derniers temps. Je crois que la
Suisse a quand même fait pas mal de
plus de chemin là-dessus que dans dans
le passé. C'est beaucoup plus compliqué
de cacher le son argent en Suisse.
D'ailleurs, il me semble que les
Français vont plus tellement en Suisse
maintenant le faire.
C'est à cause d'un chirurgien spécialisé
dans les cheveux.
Oui. Alors lui ça ça n'a effectivement
pas aidé.
Tu te rappelles de son nom
Jérôme Kausac ? Ouais mais alors c'est
pas c'est pas le seul hein. On a souvent
des HSBC Leak, des Swiss Leak, des
machins. On découvre un peu des trucs et
il faut quand même dire qu'une fois que
les États-Unis ont commencé à venir
réclamer des noms d'Américains qui
cachaient, ça a beaucoup fait bouger les
choses parce qu'on a quand même un peu
les boules.
Vous avez un peu peur des Américains ?
Ben, on peut pas tellement rivaliser,
hein. On est 8 millions d'habitants. Euh
le le plan pendant la Seconre mondiale,
c'était de se cacher dans les montagnes.
C'est toujours le même plan d'ailleurs.
Alors non, il a été abandonné.
Maintenant euh ça s'appelait le réduit
national. C'est-à-dire que dans les
montagnes, ils ont creusé dans certaines
montagnes et le but c'était toute la
population, on aurait abandonné le pays
aux Allemands ou aux alliés parce qu'on
savait pas. Nous, on était on attendait
de voir qui gagnait avant de prendre
partie. et nous on se serait caché dans
les montagnes et on aurait défendu en
gros les ponts et les tunnels. Mais
c'est assez particulier comme parti
prix. Ça veut dire queon vous laisse le
pays, on vous laisse les villes et puis
nous on attend que ça passe dans les
montagnes. Mais non, c'est plus le plan
maintenant. Je sais pas ce que c'est le
plan mais c'est plus ça.
Est-ce que tu as entendu parler d'un
exercice militaire qui s'appelle Stabilo
doué ? Ah oui, je me souviens plus
exactement ce que c'était mais c'était
récent ça. Bah ça date quand même un peu
je dirais on va demander à la communauté
de nous fa checker mais je crois que ça
a plus de 5 ans 4 ans quelque chose
comme ça.
C'estd que il s'attend du moins le
gouvernement suisse s'attend à un afflux
massif de réfugiés économiques ou
climatiques mais plutôt économique du
Portugal, de France, d'Italie et des
pays de Mitrophe. Donc il serait capable
de fermer le pays en moins de 24 heures.
Frontière tout tout. C'est le pays
étanche. Tu as pas entendu parler de ça
? Ben ça me dit quelque chose mais des
exercices, on en a souvent parce qu'en
fait nous on a quand même une armée de
milice. C'est-à-dire que tout Suisse en
âge d'exercer euh de en âge d'être
majeur et de d'avoir le droit de vote,
tout ça doit effectuer son service
militaire ou alors se faire réformer. Ce
que j'ai réussi à faire, Dieu merci.
Mais
réformé quoi ? P4. On n passé les
abréviations. Moi, j'étais réformé.
Ça veut dire rien.
Ouais, mais c'est ça, c'est ça. Je suis
passé devant le psi et j'ai expliqué que
mon rapport à l'autorité était compliqué
et puis j'ai fait un peu le le geek un
peu flippant et puis du coup, ils ont
décidé de pas de pas me donner de fusil.
et dans un truc qui s'appelle la
protection civile qui est une version un
peu light de l'armée où on surveille des
parkings pour les festivals. Mais donc
il y a plein plein de Suisses qui sont
dans l'armée. Euh d'abord tu fais 5 mois
d'école de recrue puis après tu fais des
des cours de répèt tous les 2 ans de 3
semaines. Donc il faut occuper ces mecs.
Et donc les exercices à foison de il y
en avait un c'était ils ont simulé un
crash d'avion et on va s'occuper des
gens qui sont machin.
Récemment, il y avait un exercice sur le
réchauffement climatique où il y avait
plein de réfugiés climatiques et après
il y a
et là il y a des il y a des
interférences.
Ouais. Ouais. Non mais c'est un
technicien qui a qui voulait regarder
sur YouTube. Mec, tu prends ton clavier,
tu sais tu as le même en direct là.
Mais du coup Stabilo doué, je me
souviens plus en détail mais ça me
surprend pas que tu me dises ça. Et la
Suisse, elle a attaché à sa
souveraineté. C'est assez bizarre parce
qu'on est on est quand même dans les
accords de Schengen du blin.
C'est-à-dire que en théorie, il y a plus
de frontières entre la Suisse, la
France, la Suisse, l'Allemagne et la
Suisse, l'Italie. Euh, on aussi
l'Autriche, Lichtenstein comme pays
limitrophe. Mais il y a encore des
douigners, il y a encore un peu c'est un
c'est un peu on fait les choses un peu à
moitié. On n'est pas dans l'Europe mais
on va négocier séparément que des
accords bilatéraux pour avoir un peu les
mêmes conditions que l'Europe. Donc ça
me surprend pas que tu me dises qu'on
est capable de fermer le pays en 24
heures. Et je pense ça rassure beaucoup
de Suisse. Ouais,
c'est un gros coffre fort. Les Suisses,
ils ont quelle perception des migrants ?
Assez négative.
Ils sont toujours aussi racistes avec
les Polonais et comme ça ou ça a changé
? Bah maintenant c'est quand même
principalement la vag
non ? Alors les français c'est pas
considéré comme des migrants. Alors
c'est encore plus particulier parce que
quand on parle des migrants maintenant
en Suisse vraiment ceux de Méditerranée
et donc Afrique du Nord principalement
et ça ça fait peur aux gens et c'est une
peur qui est instrumentalisée notamment
par l'UDC. On a on a voté l'interdiction
des Minarets, ça a fait beaucoup parler.
Ça c'était il y a 10 ans maintenant. Euh
on vote de temps en temps des trucs un
peu racistes parce que comme on vote
pour tout ben de temps en temps ça peut
être un peu instrumentalisé.
Mais les Français, c'est les frontaliers
comme on appelle ça. C'estàdire, c'est
tous ceux qui habitent euh je je vais
pas me tromper dans les départements,
mais il y a la Savoie, il y a un peu
l'Alsace,
Jura,
le Jura qui touche la Suisse, toute la
région autour de Genève qu'on appelle le
grand Genève. Donc Ansy, Anmass,
c'est plutôt la Suisse qui touche le
Jura d'ailleurs.
Ouais, parce qu'on est encastré comme ça
dedans. En ça c'est une question de
point de vue, mais ces gens là tout au
long de la frontière, il y a plein
d'endroits qui ont assez fleuris où les
gens s'installent, ils vont travailler
en Suisse la journée et ils habitent en
France où tout est moins cher,
l'immobilier et ça eux, ils sont assez
mal vu parce qu'il y a une espèce de
sous-enère salariale où le français qui
a pas les loyers suisses à payer et les
charges suisses, il va accepter de
bosser pour moins cher et ça fait un peu
du dumping. que ça dans les quand on
limitro c'est assez mal vu et les
frontaliers sont assez mal vus notamment
parce qu'ils participent assez peu à la
vie culturelle c'est-à-dire qu'ils
viennent bosser ils font des
embouteillages le matin pour venir
bosser ils font des embouteillages le
soir quand ils rentrent chez eux et puis
ils sont là que pour ça donc ça c'est un
peu un truc négatif qui fait qu'il y a
pas mal de francophobie en Suisse en ce
moment c'est assez facile en tant
qu'humoriste de taper sur les français
de faire rire moi j'essaie de résister à
ça
genre un exemple
bah là en ce moment les grèves en Suisse
le la France c'est un peu le
contreeexemple dès qu'il y a un truc
politique qui est un peu trop de gauche
on dit "Oh, tu as vu ce qui se passe en
France ?" C'est le bordel. Puis quand il
y a un train qui est en retard, la
blague de beau, ça on est en France.
Enfin, c'est vraiment vous avez cette
image là du pays raleur toujours à
l'arrêt, tout ça. Donc ça c'est en ce
moment, c'est un peu l'image que vous
avez. Et puis c'est c'est en Suisse
francophone qu'on appelle la Suisse
romande, les Français sont assez mal vu
en ce moment et ça n'aide pas que vous
ayez gagné la Coupe du monde parce qu'il
y a quand même la jalousie et le les
Suisses ont eu l'impression et ça j'ai
jamais j'étais un peu jeune mais j'ai
jamais tellement ressenti ça que en 98
quand vous avez gagné après vous en avez
parlé pendant 20 ans mais moi j'ai pas
l'impression mais donc c'est un peu le
truc qui ressortait en 2018 c'était ah
s'il gagne de nouveau la coupe du monde
on va les entendre pendant 20 ans. On va
les entendre dire "On est les champions,
on les champion". Alors que vous avez eu
un mois à savourer ça puis après c'était
les gilets jaunes. Donc j'ai pas
l'impression qu'on vous a beaucoup
entendu mais c'est la perception qu'on
a. Les Français sont grande gueule, ils
râent tout le temps et cetera.
J'ai une question d'internet. Euh
c'était comment le baromètre de la
liberté d'expression et le climat
politique de France s'interrent selon
lui ? Le jugeant censuré Pierre Emmanuel
Barr a quitté l'émission de la bande
originale dans lequel Visel a aussi fait
des chroniques.
Ouais. Alors moi, je suis arrivé bien
après que Pierrem soit parti, enfin non
bien après la saison d'après. Euh j'ai
je me suis pas senti censuré euh du
tout. Euh
tu prenais euh d'argent
cétait vraiment pas beaucoup. C'était
200 € je crois la chronique.
C'est radin quand même. Non. Bah disons
que je payais pour travailler parce que
le train et les frais sur place parce
moi j'habitais pas en France donc
j'habite toujours pas en France, je
faisais l'aller-retour pour ma chronique
et ça me revenait
je perdais de l'argent. Après, je crois
qu'avec les droits d'auteur dont j'ai
jamais compris comment ils étaient
calculés mais je reçois des fois des
lettres de la SASM qui me disent que
j'ai gagné 13 € pour l'année 2018. Donc
je suis très content. Euh je crois que
j'étais tu as déclaré d'ailleurs
que je que je déclare mais moi euh les
Suisses nous on paye des impôts en
Suisse. Les étrangers ils en payent pas
mais nous enfin pas tous mais euh le
climat à France Inter était bon. Moi
j'ai j'étais bien dans cette émission.
J'ai arrêté parce que j'en avais marre
de faire des allers-retours parce
j'avais trop de boulot en Suisse. Je
crois qu'avec Pierem Manuel, je vais pas
parler à sa place barré pardon. Euh mais
je crois que le vrai problème c'était
que c'était le climat hyper tendu de
l'entre de tour où tout le monde avait
les boules que le FN euh passe et lui il
avait fait une chronique qui avait été
perçue comme pronant euh l'abstention
et ça ça n'avait pas plu. Donc c'était
un peu une espèce de guéger entre "OK,
tu peux faire cette chronique mais à la
fin on va dire que nous on est pour le
fait de voter" machin et puis ils sont
un peu engueulés là-dessus puis il a
préféré se barrer mais son mauvais jeu
de mot. Mais je crois que
c'est des questions de ligne éditoriale
des émissions et pas des questions de
censure. Les gens qui font leurs
émissions, ils ont un devoir de
gérer le contenu éditorial de leur
émission et si ça leur plaît pas de
discuter avec les gens et puis après tu
as le choix de de le faire ou de partir.
Je sais que Guillaume Mervait eu la même
chose à Canal Plus où il avait refusé de
montrer une caricature, il a décidé de
partir et ça c'est pour moi c'est la
liberté de l'humoriste. Mais tout comme
c'est la liberté du rédacteur en chef de
dire "On préfère pas avoir ça dans cette
émission".
Euh, une autre question, on en profite
pour les questions internet. Euh, les
Suisses sont-ils ouverts sur l'humour
tabou ? Sont plus ouverts sur l'humour
tabou que les Français ? Oui. Non,
moi j'ai j'ai de la peine avec les
généralisations de nationalité parce
j'ai vraiment l'impression que ça n'a
plus tellement lieu d'être maintenant où
bah les Français regardent de l'humour
de tous les pays via internet et nous
pareil. Donc, je pense qu'en Suisse, il
y a des gens qui sont pas du tout
réceptif à cet humour. Moi, j'ai souvent
des réactions outrées, notamment parce
qu'en Suisse, il y a peu de médias, donc
c'est forcément, tu es confronté à un
public large, donc des gens qui aiment
pas mon humour sont obligés de m'écouter
parce que je suis en train de passer à
la télé ou à la Radio nationale. Donc, y
compris des retraités, des gens qui ont
pas forcément les mêmes codes, les mêmes
envies. Donc, il y a des gens qui sont
trés tout comme en France, il y a des
gens qui ont qui aiment pas l'humour
tabou. Donc la distinction Suisse-Fance
pour moi elle elle me paraît pas très
très pertinente. Après la distinction
génération un peu plus, j'ai
l'impression que les personnes
retraitées
ont un peu plus de peine avec la
vulgarité dans l'humour, avec le le
manque de respect. C'est-à-dire quand je
suis invité quelque part et que je
critique les gens qui m'ont invité, ça
peut choquer. Mais je vois pas tellement
de démarcation. J'ai l'impression que
sur mes vidéos, j'ai tout autant de
Suisses qui sont contentes d'entendre ça
que de Français qui disent "Ah, il
faudrait qu'il viennent en France le
faire." Donc, j'ai pas vu de distinction
particulière. Moi ce qui me frappe en
terme de public, c'est à Paris où
vraiment le public est difficile dans le
sens où il y a tellement d'offres
culturelles, c'est que quand le public
est dans ta salle ou dans un comédy club
où tu viens faire ton truc, il est très
sceptique au début et tu dois le
convaincre qu'il a fait le bon choix de
venir te voir toi. Il y a un truc, il
est là, les bras croisés, fais-moi
marrer. Tandis que quand tu vas en
Suisse ou en province, en France ou dans
des bledes où il se passe moins de
trucs, les gens sont contents qu'il se
passe quelque chose. Ils te sont
reconnaissants d'être venus là et ils
sont déjà un peu conquis au départ. Donc
il y a un public parisien qui est un peu
plus exigeant de part je pense la le
foisonnement culturel qu'il y a ici et
et
gentil quand même non ? Le foisonnement
culturel bah
en France en tout cas dans mon domaine
que le Parisien est prétentieux. Oui.
Bah oui, il y a quand même un peu
l'impression d'être au centre de la
francophonie, de la France et par
extension du monde parce que comme le
Parisien, il parle souvent que français,
il a l'impression que la francophonie
c'est le monde. Mais alors c'est pas le
cas de tout le monde évidemment, mais la
France est tellement structurée de façon
centralisée à Paris où tous décident à
Paris pour le reste du pays, ça veut
dire que les gens qui sont à Paris, ils
ont l'impression que il y a pas de reste
du pays, quoi. Et ça, ça me surprend
toujours parce que Paris, c'est quoi ?
Un 5e de la population de la France,
c'est pas non plus peut-être
l'Île-de-Fance un un peu plus.
Euh tandis qu'en Suisse comme on a pas
vraiment de bah déjà on a trois zones
linguistiques différentes.
les décisions
capital c'est ça
pardon
deux capitales
non une capitale Bern mais qui est la
capitale politique la capitale
économique c'est plutôt Zuriic puis
Genève c'est un peu la capitale
internationale et que les organisations
machin tout est assez décentralisé tout
est décidé au niveau cantonal il y a 26
contants pour un pays de 8 millions
d'habitant il y a vraiment des des
compants minuscules
donc on a moins ce sentiment que d'être
le centre du monde quo de et puis on est
le minuscule pays au milieu de l'Europe
sans faire partie de l'Europe donc je
pense que il y a une espèce d'humilité
naturel où on a l'impression d'être le
voisin, le petit frère tout le temps
qu'ici vous avez pas en France. Quand tu
habites à Paris, tu as vraiment
l'impression enfin tu peux vivre ta vie
sans sortir de Paris, sans jamais lire
un truc sur ce qui se passe ailleurs
qu'à Paris. Tu as l'impression que moi
en tout cas, on me demande tout le temps
quand je viens jouer à Paris machin, si
tu joues pas à Paris euh les chaînes de
télé, les radios te considèrent pas.
Moi, je me souviens que je faisais des
tournées partout en francophénie puis
les gens me disaient "Ah, tu fais quoi
ces temps ?" Puis tuas c'est juste parce
que tu es pas à Paris, tu n'existes
plus, tu disparais du radar. Donc il y a
un truc un peu ici on a l'impression
qu'on est au centre du monde mais je
comprends parce qu'il y a tellement de
monde. Surtout maintenant avec les
grèves où les gens sont sur les
trottoirs et pas dans le métro. Mach
mais il y a trop de gens à Paris. Moi ça
me en tant que suisse ça m'angoisse. Je
allez ailleurs. Il y a personne à
Montelimar, il y a personne à Roubet, je
sais pas dispatchez-vous,
répartissez-vous mieux parce que là moi
ça m'angoisse en tout cas.
Qu'est-ce que tu penses des grèves en
France ? Comment tu tu et comment tu
est-ce que tu penses que Emmanuel Macron
c'est un bon client pour faire de
l'humour ?
C'est pas le meilleur hein.
C'est qui le meilleur ?
Bah des personnages un peu plus
clivants, un peu plus euh marqués et
sont plus facile que Macron qui est un
peu qui essaie toujours d'être au
milieu, qui essaie dès que c'est chaud,
il se met en retrait, il envoie Édard
Philippe. Enfin, il y a il y a une
espèce de
ou Alexandre de Benala ou
Alexandre Benala. Bon, plus maintenant,
mais euh il y a une espèce de
de protéiformité où il essaie d'être de
de passer entre les gouttes à chaque
fois qui fait que c'est difficile, je
pense, de Vaner Macron. Alors, j'ai pas
beaucoup à le faire parce que je suis
pas ici, mais j'ai l'impression que
Hollande était facile à caricaturer.
Sarkozi aussi. Euh, Chirac. Ouais, ils
avaient tous des tics, des trucs un peu.
Macron, il est un peu un peu
transparent. Il va un peu où le vent
souffle. Donc c'est c'est plus
compliqué. Les grèves pour un Suisse,
c'est dur à comprendre parce qu'on est
Attends, le meilleur client, attends, tu
as oublié le C'est qui le meilleur en
France pour faire de l'humour ?
Je pense c'était Sarkozi. Je pense
c'était Sarko là maintenant.
Là maintenant.
Je saurais pas te dire, je sais pas sur
qui j'aurais de la facilité à écrire des
blagues. Ce que j'aime bien en France,
c'est que il y a toujours un débat sur
la place publique. Pour les humoristes,
c'est pas béni parce que soit c'est le
Burkinis, soit c'est ben là maintenant
c'est les c'est les retraites, de temps
en temps c'est le voile. Enfin, c'est
quand même souvent du côté de l'Islam.
À chaque fois qu'ils ont besoin de se
faire élire ou d'avoir des votes,
qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
Polémique sur l'islam. Mais du coup au
moins en tant qu'humoriste, il y a
toujours un débat qui cristallise un peu
l'opinion publique avec après son lot de
Zemour Ménard ou comment il s'appelle un
Twitterelli enfin tu as toujours
quelqu'un qui va dire une connerie où là
tu peux réagir tandis que nous le débat
politique est très asceptisé déjà il est
en plusieurs langues. Donc moi qui parle
pas allemand par exemple et la majorité
de mon public non plus il est un peu
inaccessible à nous. Il y a pas de gros
sujets d'actualité, donc c'est plus
difficile pour un humoriste, je pense,
de faire la politique suisse que la
politique française où vous êtes
constamment dans le débat. Vous avez
quatre chaînes de télévision qui sont
100 % du débat toute la journée. Donc ça
fait des heures.
Tu es sûr que ça s'appelle du débat ?
Alors, ils appellent ça eux du débat.
Après, est-ce que vraiment ils débattent
? Mais en tout cas, ça donne beaucoup
d'opportunités au dérapage et à la
petite phrase qui va tourner sur les
réseaux. Donc ça, j'ai l'impression que
c'est en France, c'est cool. Et des
personnages pour un humoriste, he je dis
pas que c'est bien pour le pays, je
pense ça l' pas du tout, mais pour un
humoriste égoïstement, des personnages
comme Balcani, des personnages comme
Zemour, Robert Menard, des gens qui ont
des énormes gueules et qui vont toujours
essayer d'avoir la petite phrase, c'est
assez facile après de rebondir, mais
c'est aussi assez facile de tomber dans
leur piège. Donc c'est un peu à double
tranchant quoi.
Je saute du Cocalan. On revient aux
grèves et on revient au gilets jaunes.
On a appris que le fournisseur du LBD40
était made in Schweice. C'est une c'est
une entreprise suisse. Ouais.
Ouais. Et vous en avez entendu tu en
entendu parler là-bas. Qu'est-ce que les
Suisses pensent de de voir des Français
avec un nœud qui qui tremblotte par
terre ? des mecs qui é born, des mecs
qui se reçoivent des des des bastos dans
la joue où tu vois la moitié de de la
mâchoire avec la langue qui pendouille.
Ça
ça ces images elles sont pas méga
diffusées
en Suisse.
Bah en France c'est surtout sur internet
hein. Tu les vois pas tellement dans les
médias. Euh
tu les as vu ?
J'en ai vu quelques-unes. J'en ai vu
quelques-unes assez pour que ça me
dégoûte et que j'ai pas envie de voir
les autres. Euh je suis pas je suis pas
courageux comme ça, mais on a un vrai
recul et une vraie distance par rapport
à ça. Le conflit social est très
différent chez nous et du coup la grève,
on a de la peine à comprendre. Les
manifes, on a de la peine à les
comprendre. Je crois que c'est l'année
2019 en Suisse, c'est là on a eu le plus
de manifestations parce qu'on a eu
plusieurs fois les manifes du climat
avec les jeunes et on a eu la grève des
femmes qui a eu lieu en juin où c'était
incroyable avec énormément énormément de
femmes et d'hommes dans la rue. Mais les
grèves, les manifestations de certaines
professions ou les gilets jaunes, on a
vraiment rien d'équivalent. Ils ont
lancé les gilets jaunes en Suisse devant
le palais fédéral à Berne. Je crois
qu'ils étaient 300 au sommet de la
mobilisation. Donc il y a il y a il y
avait vraiment aucun en Belgique ça a
marché. Par exemple les gilets jaunes,
il y a eu deux trois grosses manifes, en
Suisse pas du tout. Donc il y a Ouais.
une espèce d'incompréhension de la façon
dont se déroule le débat politique euh
et le débat civil en France. Euh nous
d'une part, ben il y a le référendum, il
y a l'initiative populaire. Donc s'il y
a un vrai sujet qui cristallise,
tu lances une récolte de signature et
puis on va voter. Bon ça prend une
plombe he parce que tu récoltes pendant
des mois, tu déposes devant le parlement
le temps que ça arrive en session
parlementaire qu'ils en débattent, qui
proposent ça au votes. En général, tu as
2 3 ans puis tu as déjà oublié pourquoi
tu avais lancé le le débat. Mais ça fait
que ça calme toujours le débat
politique. C'est le débat politique est
très lent, très posé, très asceptisé et
il y a pas cette espèce de sanguinité
que vous avez chez vous où c'est il faut
que le mec démissionne. Déjà en Suisse,
on sait pas qui est le président, on
sait pas qui est la présidente en
général. Donc le Macron d'émission,
c'est compliqué parce que tu vois là
c'est Simoneta Somaruga depuis une
semaine, on change tous les 1ers janvier
et du coup je pense que la majorité de
la Suisse ne sait pas que c'est Somarga
qui est présidente et le titre de
président est symbolique, c'est-à-dire
que c'est juste un ministre qui doit
faire les discours en plus mais il a pas
de pouvoir en plus. Donc il y a un il y
a un pouvoir décentralisé qui fait que
c'est moins facile de s'offusquer parce
qu'on sait pas trop vers qui s'ofusquer,
on sait pas trop de quoi s'ofusquer.
Donc quand on voit ce qui se passe en
France, déjà on comprend mieux vos
conflits sociaux que les nôtres. Et on a
quand même un truc de pourquoi est-ce
qu'ils sont tout le temps en grève
machin. On comprend pas que c'est comme
ça que le débat public a avancé en
France. Les avancées sociales sont
faites via la rue parce qu'en Suisse
c'était pas le cas. On a même tendance à
attendre que vous fassiez les trucs et
voir si ça marche puis après de les
adopter une fois que ça a marché.
Euh plutôt que de d'expérimenter nous
des trucs, on est plutôt des suiveurs.
Donc les gilets jaunes, ouais. En
Suisse, c'était plutôt
pour ma part et mon entourage en tout
cas, on était plutôt incrédule
de la violence du mouvement et de la
longueur enfin de la violence de des
manifestations et de la répression et de
la longueur du mouvement. parce que nous
un un truc qui dure plus de tr semaines,
on a jamais vu ça quoi. Donc c'était et
là tous mes potes se foutent de ma
gueule que je vienne à Paris un mois au
pic de la grève des transports et ils
sont tous en train de me souhaiter bonne
chance, bon courage et de se moquer de
moi.
Ça se passe bien.
Moi je suis arrivé hier et aujourd'hui
j'ai quand même beaucoup marché
mais pour l'instant ça se passe bien. Je
sais pas moi, je j'ai pas à me lever à
l'aube et à essayer de prendre un R qui
est qui est supprimé. Donc je
qui est blindé
qui est blindé et puis elle me fait
engueuler par mon patron parce que je
suis en retard alors que j'habite en
banlieu moi j'ai je suis humoriste tout
va bien ma vie est privilégiée. J'ai
l'impression que c'est un peu plus
difficile pour les gens lambda qui
doivent travailler enfin lambda c'est
peut-être un peu concendant mais je moi
je me considère pas comme quelqu'un qui
est touché par ça parce que moi j'ai le
temps de m'organiser toute la journée.
Comment la Suisse elle elle s'occupe des
des gens précarisés ? Comment elle
s'occupe de ses SDF ? Comment elle
s'occupe de ses toxicomanes ? Comment
elle s'occupe des gens en difficulté ?
Bah si tu demandes au gouvernement qui
est souvent chez nous de centre droite
voire de droite, il y a pas d'argent
pour s'occuper de ces gens-là. Alors je
sais pas comment il gèreent l'argent
parce qu'il y a toujours des excédents
budgétaires de partout mais il y a
jamais l'argent pour s'occuper de ça. Il
y a quand même, je crois, faudrait qu'il
me corrige la communauté mais un Suisse
sur h qui est aux alentours du seuil de
pauvreté ou en dessous. Donc c'est pas
le pays où tout le monde est riche comme
on pourrait le dire le cliché. Il y a
une richesse moyenne qui est très élevée
parce qu'il y a d'énormes fortunes mais
il y a quand même des gens qui
souffrent. Euh il y a un filet social
qui est moins développé qu'en France. De
nouveau, il y a pas de SMIC, il y a pas
de RSA, il y a des aides sociales qui
sont un peu difficile et comme le coût
de la vie est beaucoup plus élevé, c'est
c'est c'est compliqué pour les gens qui
sont on a beaucoup de working port, des
gens qui ont qui ont un travail mais qui
arrivent pas à s'en sortir. Les mères
célibataires, c'est très précair, je
sais pas. Alors moi, j'ai jamais été
dans cette situation. J'ai beaucoup de
chance. Je sais qu'en Suisse, c'est
galère parce que l'État est moins
présent. Il y a moins l'état providence
qu'en France, donc c'est moins facile.
Il y a plein de gens, je crois, qui ont
droit à des aides et qu'ils le savent
pas et qui les obtiennent pas parce que
c'est de nouveau, c'est compliqué. C'est
à Bern, c'est en allemand machin. Donc
je sais pas comment la Suisse s'en
occupe. La Toxicomanie, je crois que on
était assez pionnier. Euh, on avait une
conseillère fédérale qui s'appelait Rot
Dryfus qui a été une des premières à
dire qu'il fallait donner des doses au
Toxicoman, qu'il fallait pas juste les
sevrer et cetera. Donc ça, je crois que
c'est un des seuls trucs où on a osé
être un peu innovateur.
Euh, les SDF, on en a moins qu'en
France, j'ai l'impress. En tout cas,
visuellement, le climat est un peu plus
rude aussi en Suisse. Donc, ils ont
peut-être tendance à à aller ailleurs
que rester dans la rue. La tu vas
jamais.
Alors si, il y en a. Ouais, il y en a.
Alors, nous c'est des réseaux organisés
beaucoup. Les Romes sont assez présents.
Les Albanais,
non, les Albanais sont plutôt intégrés.
C'est des c'est des
intégrés mais ils font l'objet de
racisme aussi non ?
Ah ouais, ils sont pas très
appréciés de certains pont de la
population mais c'est une on a eu
énormément d'immigration des Balcans à
la fin des années 90 pendant la guerre
de Bosnie. Euh donc moi, j'ai grandi en
étant à l'école avec beaucoup de
bosniacs, de de Kosovars, d'Albanais.
Ceux qui sont arrivés tout petits, ils
sont bien intégrés, ils ont fait l'école
et c'est pas rare de retrouver à
l'université et cetera. ceux qui sont
arrivés à l'adolescence ou plus vieux
qui ont vécu la guerre, c'est forcément
pas le même bagage et c'était forcément
un peu plus difficile. Euh après, c'est
fou parce qu'on est très heureux de les
avoir en équipe de de Suisse parce qu'on
fait nos meilleurs résultats qu'on a
jamais fait. On est très heureux de
plein de trucs. Ils font beaucoup
l'armée alors que le Suisse de souche,
même si c'est un truc qui se dit pas
mais celui qui a des origines élvétiques
va essayer de se faire réformer tandis
que l'Albanais est content de faire
l'armée parce que il a vécu peut-être
ses parents ont vécu un conflit armé.
Donc on est très content de les avoir
dans les rangs de l'armée, mais après un
peu comme ici avec certaines
populations, ils vont être discriminés à
l'emploi, discriminés au logement, des
trucs comme ça. Mais non, les les
mendiants, c'est plus des des Romes qui
qui viennent en Suisse parce que comme
le niveau de vie est un peu plus élevé,
en mendiant un tout petit peu en Suisse,
ils peuvent renvoyer à la famille puis
ils ont peut-être plus que s'ils
m'indient en France ou en Italie. Mais
ça c'est Ouais, c'est des c'est des
thématiques assez compliquées ça.
Si tu avais l'opportunité de transmettre
à la France
ce qui fonctionne bien en Suisse, les
points forts de la Suisse, tu choisirais
quoi ?
Je pense que la décentralisation, c'est
un truc qui est qui est qui m'a l'air de
bien fonctionner en Suisse. C'est-à-dire
que si tu essaies de gérer des problèmes
de 60 millions de personnes depuis un
bureau à Paris, ça me paraît compliqué.
En Suisse, on est déjà 8 millions, donc
c'est déjà beaucoup plus simple. Et en
plus, on compartimentalise beaucoup et
et j'ai l'impression que c'est plus
efficace
de chercher des solutions un peu
customisées, un peu adapté à un plus
gros plus petit groupe parce que les la
réalité de la personne qui est dans les
vauges, j'ai pas la même que celle qui
est en Île-de-France ou en Bretagne.
Donc ça c'est un truc, je sais, c'est
sûrement historique. On pourrait
m'expliquer pourquoi tout se passe à
Paris, mais moi ça me dépasse de et je
me dis la la personne qui est dans un
petit blé en province doit se sentir
totalement délaissé de voir que quand tu
regardes le le JT, 90 % du JT va traiter
de problèmes qui se passent à Paris et
de décisions qui se prennent à Paris. Et
puis il y a de temps en temps
Jean-Pierre Perna qui vient à la forire
de la truffe à côté de chez toi, mais tu
as pas l'impression d'exister tellement
et ça ça me surprend en France. Donc je
dirais ouais donner plus de pouvoir aux
régions, je sais qu' c'est à chaque fois
de le faire et que ça se fait pas, plus
de pouvoir au département essayer de
faire en sorte que le n'est que plus
ultra pour un politicien soit pas de
monter à Paris dès que ça marche pour
lui et puis de délaisser totalement sa
région d'avoir peut-être une permanence
où on met un assistant ou sa femme
pour en revendre derrière.
Ouais, mais et ça ça me dépasse un peu
sa femme hein.
H sa femme. Ouais, mais ouais, ça c'est
un truc, j'ai l'impression que ça
fonctionne bien en Suisse. Le fait que
les décisions se prennent au plus proche
du peuple. On a les étrangers qui
peuvent voter au niveau communal
et cantonal dans certains cantons. Donc
ça permet aussi une meilleure
intégration euh parce qu'ils se sont
concernés par les par les discussions
politiques. Donc ça ça fonctionne bien.
Euh est-ce que j'aurais d'autres trucs
qui fonctionnent bien ? Suisse, le
système de formation est assez efficace
en Suisse où si tu es pas très scolaire,
tu peux rapidement faire un
apprentissage à la fin de l'école
obligatoire où là tu vas avoir 2 jours
de cours par semaine et 3 jours en
entreprise. Et ça permet à plein de gens
qui qui ont fait des conneries ou qui
étaient pas très intéressés par les
études à 14 ans de pas totalement sortir
du système, de quand même obtenir un
diplôme, de pouvoir après faire d'autres
formations
à l'allemande.
Ouais, je crois que je crois que les
Allemands sont inspirés de nous. On a un
peu c'est un peu similaire. Ouais. Et ça
c'est un système, je crois qu'il y a
souvent des politiciens étrangers qui
viennent en Suisse observer ce système
éducatif et j'ai l'impression qu'il
fonctionne parce que moi autour de moi,
je vois plein de potes qui sont passés
par des filières très différentes pour
arriver dans des jobs séminaires. C'est
pas comme en France où j'ai l'impression
que si tu rates un peu les prépas au
début ou les sélections des grandes
écoles machin, tu es directement mis un
peu sur une zone un un peu en dessous et
puis c'est l'entreoit des des hautes
écoles et des et des gens qui ont plus
payé des tweeters très rapidement qui
qui dominent un peu. Donc ça en Suisse,
j'ai l'impression que l'égalité des
chances au niveau éducatif fonctionne.
Après la liste des choses qui
fonctionnent pas est aussi assez longue.
Alors ce qui fonctionne pas en Suisse,
bah il y a un vrai désintérêt pour la
chose publique qui fait que les les
décisions politiques se prennent
totalement euh coupé de la population.
On on comprend pas, on on s'intéresse
pas trop à ce qui se passe. Les lobby
sont très présents, je disais tout à
l'heure, mais on sait pas qui financent
les partis politiques. C'est pas du tout
ouvert. Donc il pourrait y avoir
vraiment des influences de tous les
côtés, y compris étrangères, y compris
les multinationales qui sont très
puissantes en Suisse. Ça c'est un autre
gros problème. On a vraiment des grosses
grosses entreprises qui ont énormément
de pouvoir en Suisse, l'UBS, le Crédit
Suisse, Nestle, des trucs comme ça qui
sont des mastodontes au niveau mondial.
Alors pour un pays de la taille de la
Suisse, c'est inimaginable le pouvoir
qu'ils ont et qui eux ont vraiment un
pouvoir d'influence sur les décisions
politiques dont on se rend pas vraiment
compte, je pense en tant que suisse. Et
puis ouais, bon, on l'a parlé un peu
mais en Suisse, c'est un peu marche ou
crève. Si tu es dans les gens qui s'en
sortent, qu' on un bon travail, un bon
salaire, c'est très bien. Et dès que tu
es un peu moins performant ou dans une
filière qui est un peu moins lucrative,
tu galères. Les artistes en Suisse, j'ai
énormément de chance. On a parlé de mes
revenus avant, tout se passe bien. Mais
mes potes qui sont euh musiciens, qui
sont comédiens de théâtre, qui sont un
peu des artistes qui essaie de faire des
choses qui sont moins grand public, qui
sont euh moins rémunératrices, ils
galèrent, ils vivent ils vivent comme
des étudiants toute leur vie. Et ça en
France, j'ai l'impression que vous avez
compris la valeur de la culture. On
parle souvent du PIB culturel français
qui est très très élevé et il y a quand
même tout un système qui qui est mis en
place pour que les artistes survivent.
Alors, on essaie toujours de renier et
du coup, ils se ils se rebellent et ils
ont raison. Mais au moins ça existe
parce qu'en Suisse euh si tu es artiste,
tu es tu es considéré tu es tu es juste
au-dessus de chômeur quoi. C'est tu tu
es un chômeur qui se berce d'illusion je
crois pour l'économie suisse. Donc ça
c'est un peu dommage. On a l'impression
que on est fait pour être assureur ou
banquier et puis dès que tu dévis du du
chemin ben va à Paris parce que il y a
pas la place pour toi ici et ça je
trouve un peu dommage. Bon
avant de parler du cannabis.
Ah
euh là tu reviens tu étais à France
Inter c'est ça
tout à l'heure ?
avec Guillaume Meris qu'on lui passe on
lui passe le bonjour et euh et vous avez
parlé de Dieu donné ou pas ? Non non,
c'était pas un sujet
Dieu donné
dieu donné euh c'est quelqu'un qui a une
communauté très très active.
Là, il y en a certains qui viennent de
poser la question là. C'est pour ça on
enchaîne sur la question.
OK. Écoute, moi j'ai vraiment pour le
coup pas du tout suivi ce qu'il faisait
euh avant les polémiques
et après les polémiques, j'avais pas
très envie et donc j'ai vraiment pris la
porte de sortie de on m'a envoyé le
sketch sur le cancer parce que tout le
monde me disait du bien de ça et je le
trouve formidable, très bien écrit.
Euh je suis tombé de temps en temps
tombé sur des vidéos YouTube qui fait
depuis sa chambre où j'ai trouvé que je
voyais pas trop l'élément humoristique
et il y a plein de choses qui me
dépassent et c'est quelqu'un dont je
m'occupe peu. Moi je lui en veux dans le
sens où euh il a tellement brouillé les
pistes entre l'artiste, le propos de
l'artiste, l'humain, la campagne
politique, leur
le quoi ? Ah le son truc d'assurance.
Ouais, des trucs de il se plaint d'être
d'être ostracisé, d'être boycotté alors
que je pense c'est l'humoriste
francophone qui fait le plus d'argent ou
pas loin vu les salles qui remplent.
Donc je comprends pas très bien le
propos et surtout bah nous depuis et
c'est le cas de nouveau maintenant et je
vous en veux pas mais on nous pose
toujours la question sur lui donc on
doit toujours s'exprimer sur lui,
toujours se positionner par rapport à
lui alors que je sais pas moi je j'y
pense jamais en fait quand on me pose
pas la question je suis pas dans ma en
train de me demander qu'est-ce que je
pense de dieu donné. On vit très bien.
Où est le cannabis en Suisse ?
Bah le cannabis. Alors moi je je fume
pas enfin je fume très peu. C'estàd que
j'ai commencé à Montréal parce que
là-bas c'est légal. Cet été j'étais à
Montréal et du coup je me suis dit que
j'allais essayer parce que comme je suis
quelqu'un d'assez anxieux, d'assez dans
ma tête, je me suis dit que ça me ferait
du bien et c'était cool. Et en Suisse le
CBD est légal. Donc c'est le cannabis
sans THC
que j'ai pas essayé encore mais il y a
un espèce de gros boom du CBD l'année
passée. J'ai l'impression que ça se
calme un peu. Et puis il y a toujours un
peu une espèce de semi-t-olérance autour
de ça. Il y a Bernard Rapa qui est un
chanrier
très connu en Suisse qui qui a fait un
peu de la prison. Sortir de prison,
retourner en prison. Je crois que il
s'est fait connaître parce qu'il vendait
des oreillers. des oreillers. Exactement
au Paléo qui un des gros festivals un
peu comme les vieilles charrues en
Suisse. Il vendaient des oreillers à
vertu thérapeutique puis en fait quand
tu les ouvrais bah c'était du cannabis
dedans et tout le monde le savait. Donc
les gens restaient ça c'est dans les
années 80 je crois. Euh donc il y a
beaucoup de gens qui fument en Suisse
comme en France je crois. Dans les
humoristes
cultivé en Suisse ou pas ? Je crois que
tu as le droit de cultiver pour ta
consommation personnelle et je crois que
tu as le droit d'avoir pour moins de 50
francs euh donc une quarantaine d'euros
de cannabis sur toi et au-dessus tu es
considéré comme un dealer et là tu peux
avoir des problèmes. Mais euh pour ta
consommation personnelle, tu as tu as le
droit. Mais je suis pas le meilleur
là-dessus parce que j'ai j'ai jamais
fumé en Suisse.
Bon et ben personne n'est parfait.
Écoute,
comme dirait Bernard Rapa, la meilleure
B, elle vient de Suisse.
Ouais bah lui il a
il a des neurones. Euh fatigué ? Non.
Bah j'ai l'impression qu'il a beaucoup
fumé. C'est peut-être pas le meilleur
ambassadeur pour la légalisation du
cannabis. Moi, j'enverrai quelqu'un
d'autre au front que lui.
Tu enverrais qui ?
Bon, je sais pas, quelqu'un qui arrive
mieux à s'exprimer.
Alors, une question d'internet. La
Suisse a perdu son secret bancaire
depuis. Elle a investi en masse dans les
datas.
Exemple, la BNS a plus d'action Facebook
que Marc Zuckerurberg. Ah je savais pas
la 5 non plus la 5G arrive en Suisse et
il y a eu un audit dessus. Est-il au
courant ? Si oui, que pensent-il du fait
que la majorité des personnes qui
faisaient partie de l'audit
travaillaient pour l'État ou pour des
opérateurs ?
Mais ça me surprend ça.
Humorist les gars, faites attention.
Ouais, non, c'est bien. On me pose des
questions pointues, on me respecte. Euh
la 5G, ouais, il y a eu il y a eu un pas
mal de débats. Euh il y a plusieurs
cantons qui ont décidé d'un moratoire
sur la 5G. C'estàdire, on attend, ce qui
est très suisse, c'est on veut pas
prendre nous la décision, on attend de
voir comment ça se passe ailleurs. Euh
donc ça, on est là, je crois. Il y a Sof
erreur, des canton ils en installent.
Des antennes 5G, des contons ils en
installent pas. Celui où j'habite
Safreur, ils en installent pas encore.
Et à Genève non plus. Euh mais ça me
surprend pas que ce soit des opérateurs
et le et l'État qui soient dans ces
groupes. Euh moi je je vois pas le
besoin de la 5G. J'ai l'impression que
nos téléphones vont bien assez vite et
que c'est une espèce de course vers
l'avant qui me qui me dépasse un peu. Et
je me souviens plus, il avait une
première question euh mais elle était
tellement longue que
C'est ça. Fais des questions pour euh
Ah oui, la BNS. Bah la BNS, je savais
pas qu'ils avaient euh des actions
Facebook.
Ce que je sais c'est qu'ils ont eu 50
milliards d'excédents je crois où on
prédit 50 milliards de bénéfices en
2019. Et comme je disais tout à l'heure,
il y a pas d'argent pour s'occuper des
pauvres.
quand tu charges les multinationales
dans tes spectacles, pourquoi tu fais ça
?
Mais alors, je le fais je le fais pas
dans mes spectacles. D'ailleurs, mon
spectacle actuel, je parle beaucoup de
moi. Euh,
tu parles de tes testicules ou pas ?
Ça c'était dans celui d'avant. Ça c'est
Je suis passé à autre chose. Maintenant,
un petit peu quand même parce que ça
reste un sujet important mais ma
stérilité, non, j'en ai parlé avant.
Deux patients c'est le fils fucking et
béton. Ah
oui, j'ai dit ça quelques Non, je c'est
un exemple que je donnais. Euh, j'aime
pas trop Bethoven, mais euh
quand je suis invité dans une dans un
événement privé, je vais pas commencer à
parler de mes testicules pour prendre ça
comme exemple par ça intéresse pas les
gens qui sont
par contre tu mets tes couilles sur la
table quand tu dis euh Nestley euh
acheter du lait à Mugouabé, ça a dû
quand même faire mal en face, non ?
Oui, mais alors de nouveau, c'était pas
Nesley qui m'engageait puis c'était pas
des actionnaires Nestle en face. Mais
quand je vais quelque part, je regarde
qui va y avoir, qui sont ces gens, c'est
des sportifs, des politiciens, des
hommes d'affaires, des femmes
d'affaires. Et je vais m'adapter, je
vais faire des blagues sur eux. Et dans
ces blagues, souvent c'est mon point de
vue qui est plutôt du côté
anticapitaliste,
un peu communiste, anarchiste comme ça
qui va ressortir.
Mais c'est parce que les gens sont en
face de moi. Quand je suis en face de
gens de gauche, bah je vais faire des
blagues sur les gens de gauche qui sont
en face de moi. En général, j'ai quand
même l'impression mais c'est de nouveau
parce que moi je suis à gauche que même
les gens de gauche qui sont pas
exactement au même endroit que moi, ils
sont moins éloignés que ceux qui sont à
l'autre bord. Donc c'est plus facile
pour moi de charger Péter Brabec,
l'ex-patron de Nestle, que de charger un
socialiste parce que j'ai des choses en
commun avec lui. Mais j'essaie de le
faire quand c'est un socialiste en face
de moi, je fais des blagues sur lui. Moi
je suis humoriste. Mon mon but, c'est de
faire rire. Euh si je peux faire rire et
en plus défendre un point de vue qui
m'est cher et en plus un peu égratigner
des gens dont j'aime pas ce qu'ils font,
c'est tout bonus. Mais le but c'est
d'être drôle. Moi jamais je ferai une
blague qui est pas drôle juste parce que
je me dis non mais ça le point de vue
est bien. Donc si je trouve pas la punch
comme on dit, si je trouve pas la chute
bah je vais pas la faire.
Qu'est-ce qui avait dit si vous dites
des choses aux gens si vous ne le dites
pas avec humour il vous comprend la tête
ou quelque chose comme ça ? Tu vois pas
qui je la communauté
la communauté va nous retrouver ça
et qui
moi c'est j'ai un humoriste suisse que
peut-être la communauté me connaît et
qu'il faudrait qu'il découvre parce le
plus drôle il s'appelle Nathanael Rocha
et il m'a beaucoup aidé. C'est un peu
mon mentor. Lui il me disait toujours
quand je faisais des chroniques engagé
il faut que tu mettes un truc
intelligent une connerie. Un truc
intelligent une connerie et garder
vraiment il faut faire rire les gens et
tant que tu fais rire les gens ils
t'écoutent. Et si tu commences à être
que chiant, que militant, que je vais
vous expliquer ce que vous devez penser
là, tu perds tout le monde. Si tu es
drôle et en plus il y a des idées
derrière, tu as des chances de passer un
message. Si tu es juste et les gars, moi
j'ai compris vous pas, à mon avis, tu
perds tout le monde et c'est un métier
différent et moi je sais pas le faire.
Donc j'essaie toujours de garder pas mal
de conneries dans ce que je dis.
Alors la source pour les actions du
Curberg, du moins la BNS a plus
d'actions que Facebook que Z duurberg,
c'est tribunal tribune de Genève. CH.
Bah voilà,
merci à la communauté et merci à IO.
On salue la presse suisse.
Écoute, la presse suisse a l'air de
faire quand même un peu plus le taf que
la presse française. Qu'est-ce que tu en
penses ?
Bah, on est en tout cas en terme de qui
possède la presse suisse, ça me fait
moins peur que chez vous. Euh où on voit
toujours ces schémas où ça remonte à
quatre personnes. Ouais.
Pas loin. Bon, il y a certains de ceux
qui possèdent des médias chez vous qui
habitent chez nous. Donc ça c'est un
autre problème encore. Mais écoute, on a
des on a des bons des bons médias. On a
quand même des médias public qui sont
performants, même si on leur coupe, tu
vois, dans les budgets, et qui sont
hyper indépendants. C'est-à-dire que
c'est pas le président qui va mettre des
gens à la tête et qui va pouvoir essayer
d'influencer la la politique éditoriale.
C'est hyper indépendant. Euh ce qui pour
les gens en Suisse veut dire que c'est
de gauche, mais moi j'ai pas
l'impression parce que c'est quand même
souvent assez quand même libéral. Euh
mais on a de l'information de qualité
sur ce qui se passe en Suisse. Après sur
la politique internationale, bah ils ont
plus assez d'argent pour envoyer des
gens. Donc c'est beaucoup euh on
commence à avoir beaucoup d'articles du
monde qui sont repris, beaucoup de
dépêches, des trucs comme ça forcément
parce qu'il faut bien économiser quelque
part mais sur la politique suisse sur
moi je consomme énormément de sport sur
le sport suisse le sport en général on
est on est vraiment bien servi avec nos
médias. Moi je trouve qu'on a de la
chance mais pourtant on a des polémiques
régulièrement. On a voté l'année passée,
on en a un peu parlé en France parce que
vous avez le même problème avec la
redevance.
où il y avait une initiative populaire
qui voulait abolir la redevance et donc
assassiner les médias publics parce que
tu peux pas faire tourner un média
public sans redevance. et ça a été sauvé
mais c'était un débat qui était
extrêmement houleux avec une bonne
partie de la population qui voulait
arrêter de payer la redevance alors que
c'est un bal ce qui est pas non plus
excessif il me semble pour un média de
qualité mais nous je dis nous parce que
moi je bossais à la télévision d'état à
l'époque avec une émission satirique
c'était assez violent parce qu'on avait
plus le droit enfin on était méga cadré
dans le sens vous avez pas le droit de
parler de cette campagne on a un devoir
de neutralité donc c'était assez
horrible tu étais pendant 6 mois au dans
l'œil du cyclone et comme tu étais dans
le cyclone tu avais pas le droit de
parler
Et après une fois que la votation est
passée, on a pu un peu s'exprimer et
s'amuser avec ça. Mais pendant pendant
quelques mois, nos patrons, ils étaient
tellement
la censure quoi.
C'était plus c'était pas vraiment de la
censure mais c'était
d'autocensure un peu forcé,
un peu d'autocensure, mais surtout en
fait c'était la mission de service
public. Tu as pas le droit enfin pendant
les votations si tu donnes un point de
vue, tu dois donner le point de vue
inverse. Donc si on faisait nous des
blagues comme quoi on a l'impression que
les médias public étaient de bonne
qualité, on devait à chaque fois inviter
un opposant qui disait le contraire. Et
pour une émission de blague, d'inviter
des gens pas drôles dans ton émission
pour défendre ce point de vue, c'était
pas possible. Donc le seul point ce
qu'on a
Ils sont pas drôles
hein.
Pourquoi ils sont pas drôles ?
Parce qu'ils sont politiciens. Parce
qu'il y a pas c'était pas des humoristes
en face. Si tu dès que tu invites des
opposants, c'est pas des gens qui font
des blagues. Donc
c'était pas possible pour nous de faire
un sketch sur ce sujet-là et puis après
d'avoir 4 minutes où tu as un initiant
antiedevance qui nous explique pourquoi
on a tort. Donc on a attendu que la
votation passe puis on en a parlé après
coup.
Alors, deux questions, on prend une.
Peut-on encore être drôle quand tu as
quand l'heure n'est plus à la rigolade ?
Attention les question. Attends. Quand
l'heure n'est plus à la rigolade, mais
dans l'action de la réalisation.
Mais moi,
je pense que
moi je suis nul dans l'action et genre
pas ça.
Non mais bien sûr,
mais tu es nul dans l'action, tu es
opératif. Tu tu tu lates tu lates en
face du mec de chez Nesley,
tu le lates.
Pareil, j'ai regardé sur internet ton
ton show avec les les les rois de
l'immobilier suisse.
Ouais,
c'est un mourir de rire.
Mais mais moi ce que je veux dire c'est
que moi je sais faire ça. Je sais je
sais écrire des blagues, je sais faire
des blagues. Peut-être ça fait rire les
gens, peut-être ça les fait pas rire,
peut-être ça les fait réfléchir, ça les
fait pas réfléchir. Mais quand on me dit
pourquoi tu vas faire des blagues envers
ces gens et tu fais pas plutôt c plutôt
ça ? Parce que moi je sais rien faire
d'autre. C'est vraiment ça.
Tu sais faire de la comptabilité
mais même pas tellement. Elle a fait
faillite la boîte. Donc je suis pas très
bon làdedans et je fais même plus ma
propre compa pour te dire à quel point
je suis un anti maintenant. Mais j'ai
l'impression que opposer les combats
c'est pas terrible et puis qu'il faut
chacun
faire selon ses compétences, sa
spécificité. Et moi, j'ai jamais
l'énergie pour aller manifester. Quand
il y a une manife en bas de chez moi,
j'ai la flemme de descendre. Euh je suis
pas du tout quelqu'un d'action d'aller
dans des réunions, d'aller rencontrer
des gens, discuter, je sais pas faire.
Ce que je sais faire, c'est chercher des
infos sur internet, en sortir des
blagues de temps en temps les filmer et
mettre sur internet et pour moi, on aura
toujours la le besoin de rire. Et même
une fois que la planète sera en train
d'exploser, j'espère qu'il y aura encore
des gens pour nous faire rire pendant
qu'elle explose. Là, tous les mêmes et
les blagues sur internet sur la troisème
guerre mondiale me font mourir de rire.
J'ai pas vu. Ça ressemble.
Ah ben c'est c'est que des en Suisse,
c'est beaucoup le fait qu'il y aura une
troisème guerre mondiale et que nous on
fera rien du tout et ça ça me fait
mourir de rire. Mais c'est tous les
trucs aux États-Unis sur où ils vont se
cacher quand l'armée viendra les
chercher pour faire la guerre. Tout ça
c'est c'est très c'est surtout des gens
très jeunes qui font ça. Mais moi ça me
fait beaucoup rire et pour moi c'est pas
incompatible la gravité d'une situation
et le fait d'en rire. Et c'est même plus
c'est grave plus c'est important d'en
rire. Rire des choses rigolotes à la
base c'est bien aussi mais c'est quand
même plus facile. Rire des choses
tragiques, tristes, duré.
C'est salutaire.
Autre question de Pierre. Bonjour. Je
voulais savoir si Thomas Visel n'avait
pas peur de servir le pessimisme ambiant
l'attendant en s'amusant des injustices.
Bah, c'est un peu la même question.
Ouais. Euh est-ce que quand on fait une
blague sur les injustices, on on les
normalise ou on les pointe du doigt ou
on aide à garder ça dans le débat public
? S'amuser ne veut pas dire forcément
moquer, tourner en dérision. On peut
pour moi, on peut faire une blague sur
une injustice en se mettant du côté des
gens qui sont minorisés et qui sont dans
l'injustice.
Moi, mon job, c'est de faire rire. Si
j'ai pas fait rire, j'ai pas fait mon
job et c'est dur de faire rire tout le
monde. Donc, il y a toujours une
proportion pour lesquelles j'ai pas fait
le job. Mais quand je peux mettre le
projecteur sur un problème, je suis
content et j'ai aucunement la préten
mais c'est pas moi qui vais le faire. Ça
c'est pour ça
un peu lanceur d'alerte.
Ouais, pourquoi pas ? C'est c'est je
trouve ça assez noble en tout cas les
lanceurs d'
trop de risque si. Alors une question
d'innet de quel réseau de quel réseau
entre parenthèses compte de réseau
social, journal radio et cetera vient la
plus grosse attaque critique qu'il a
subi
de quel réseau ?
Je pense c'était Facebook. C'était des
messages sur Facebook le pire c'était
les nationalistes turcs. J'avais fait
une une chronique sur Erdogan à
l'époque. Il s'était attaqué, il avait
porté plainte contre un humoriste
allemand qui avait fait un un poème
satirique sur lui et il avait porté
plainte pour l'es majesté parce qu'il
restait une loi archaïque dans le code
pénal allemand pour l' Majesté. Et du
coup, j'avais fait une chronique où je
me foutais de sa gueule en solidarité
avec humoriste allemand et ça avait été
diffusé dans des réseaux nationaliste
turc de son parti. Euh ouais, notamment
notamment des des Français. Il me
semblait que c'était beaucoup des des
Turcs de France.
Euh et là, j'avais reçu énormément de
menaces de mort, d'insultes, de menaces
d'agression physique. Des gens
m'envoyaient des des affiches de mon
spectacle avec des trucs marqués dessus
en disant "On sera là à telle date." Et
euh
connu la police,
j'avais transmis à un policier qui m'a
dit que
tant que c'était une fois, c'estàdire
tant que la personne avait une menace
qui était pas réitérée, ils agissaient
pas. S'il y avait une personne qui
réitérait des menaces ou qui devenait
spécifique, fallait leur dire. Et pour
le coup, il avait eu raison parce que
j'avais eu plein de gens qui m'ont
menacé une fois et de semaines après,
j'avais plus rien. Et j'ai jamais eu un
Turc qui m'a menacé dans la vraie vie,
c'était que sur internet. Après, j'ai eu
en Suisse, il les ressortissons turcs
sont plutôt de la minorité kurde, donc
plutôt opposé à Erdogan. Donc, j'ai j'ai
l'impression que j'avais moins à
craindre en Suisse qu'en France. Mais
euh j'ai eu beaucoup aussi les sionistes
que j'avais fait une chronique sur Gaza
une fois qui avait pas mal tourné sur
des pages à la fois proalestine et à la
fois anti-palestine. Et du coup, j'avais
eu quelques messages de soutien et
beaucoup de messages de gens parce quand
on s'appelle Visel et qu'on soutient pas
la politique d'État d'Israël, euh c'est
problématique parce que c'est un
patronyme juif. Moi je suis pas juif
mais ma famille l'était. Donc ça c'était
assez violent pendant quelques semaines
aussi. J'avais eu qui les pro Ramadan
quand Tar Ramadan Tarik Ramadan pas
Ramadan le mois de jeûne qui est Suisse
lui et qui a sévant
en France. Alors, tout ça est encore en
cours de de jugement, mais il y a
beaucoup beaucoup d'accusations et
j'avais fait une chronique là-dessus au
début de l'accusation et là pour le
coup, c'est la seule fois où j'ai senti
que c'était organisé dans le sens où
c'est que des comptes qui venaient
d'être créés, qui avaient zéro followers
et c'était à la fois YouTube et Facebook
où c'était tous les mêmes éléments de
langage avec quelques mots qui
changeaient. Donc, on sentait vraiment
que c'était un espèce de groupe de
soutien organisé qui m'avait bombardé de
400 messages en 5 jours puis après de
nouveau ça s'est calmé. Donc j'ai eu des
sheet storm mais j'ai pas eu de trucs
qui m'ont vraiment
impacté personnellement. La seule fois
où c'était physique et personnel,
c'était le club de foot dont on parlait
tout à l'heure où je Lausan
Lausan Lausan Sport où j'avais fait une
blague sur un joueur qui
était pas terrible. Ça je l'ai jamais
nié.
C'est quoi la blague ?
En fait c'est un joueur qui avait été
accusé d'agression sexuelle en
Angleterre. Il y avait eu une enquête et
il avait été blanchi. Et moi la blague
que j'avais fait c'est moi je savais
qu'il était innocent parce que 8 ans de
carrière tris but il est incapable de la
mettre au fond. Voilà. Donc c'est une
blague très grivoise pas très maline. Ça
me faisait rire. Ce que j'avais pas
anticipé c'est que ce joueur-là
évidemment avait traversé un enfer
pendant toutes ces enquêtes là. Il
voulait pas que ce soit remis sur le sur
le devant dans les médias tout ça. Et du
coup il a mal réagi. Il m'a croisé
après. Il m'a un peu pris à parti comme
sur un terrain de foot. C'est-à-dire que
j'ai fait un tacle par derrière et il a
réagi comme si on lu avait fait un tacle
par derrière. Le problème c'est que je
sais pas qui a alerté la presse de ce
qui s'était passé alors que c'était dans
le parking et du coup ça a fait les gros
titres en Suisse et malheureusement pour
lui tout le monde n'a parlé que de cette
blague alors que j'avais fait 35 minutes
de blagues sur le club de foot dont la
plupart c'était sur la performance du
club de foot qui était relégué cette
saison là donc c'était catastrophique.
Mais vu qu'il y a eu cette altercation
physique tout le monde n'a parlé que de
cette blague. Donc le pauvre il y a eu
le les projecteurs sur ce cet épisode de
sa vie qui voulait plutôt passer sous
silence. Donc c'était un peu un autogal
pour lui et de la pub pour moi, mais là,
elle était pas très bonne. Mais sinon,
j'ai jamais rien eu. C'est pour ça des
fois quand on me dit sur internet que je
suis courageux, moi j'ai pas
l'impression, j'écris des blagues, je
vais les dire, je rentre chez moi, il y
a pas je fais mon job quoi. C'est pas
c'est pas plus impressionnant qu'autre
chose. Il y a plein de trucs qui
m'impressionnent beaucoup plus que ça
parce que moi tout ce que je sais faire,
c'est les blagues.
Bah les gens qui vraiment
s'investissent, qui donnent du temps
pour organiser des actions. Là en
Suisse, on a eu tout un groupe qui a
manifesté dans une
sucursale Crédit Suisse pour protester
contre les investissements dans les
énergies fossiles de Crédit Suisse et
ils ont joué au tennis parce que Crédit
Suisse sponsorise Federair et du coup
ils ils ont centré leur campagne autour
de Federair de dire que Federair doit se
réveiller et se désolidariser de crédit
suisse. Et ils ont bloqué la banque et
là ils sont en procès. Donc ça c'est des
gens qui ont pris du temps pour
organiser une action manifesté. Ils ont
été arrêtés, ils ont des frais
judiciaires, ils sont en procès
actuellement, il y a des impacts sur
leur vie personnelle, leur vie
professionnelle. Ça ça m'impressionne.
Moi, faire une blague, gagner de
l'argent, souvent je suis payé pour mes
blagues et rentrer chez moi, regarder ma
petite série et m'endormir. Euh, je suis
dans un certain confort et et je suis
content de ça. Donc, j'ai pas
l'impression que les les félicitations
me reviennent, quoi.
Tu es prêt tu es prêt à risquer quoi euh
dans ta vie pour faire quelque chose ?
Mais pas grand-chose. Moi, je suis
vraiment pas courageux.
Non, moi j'ai j'ai pas du tout le goût
du risque. Euh, on parlait de Mike Horn
tout à l'heure qu'un autre il y a pas
Ça te fait que Mike Horn soit suisse.
Avant, il était sud-africain.
Alors, il est pas suisse mais il habite
en Suisse. Ses filles sontsees. Son sa
femme qui est décédée était Suisse
à son âme.
Puis à son âme. Euh et du coup, on en
parle beaucoup en Suisse, encore plus
qu'en France où il est quand même
présent dans les médias. Et là, moi ça
me laisse de marbre parce que c'est
quelqu'un qui prend énormément de risque
tout le temps, qui a cette adrénaline du
risque et qui a frôé la mort 150 fois.
Et moi, je suis l'extrême opposé. Moi si
je peux rester dans mon dans mon
appartement le plus possible, de temps
en temps sortir et revenir, je suis très
content. Aller à Paris, c'est le sommet
du risque que je suis prêt à prendre.
Passer les grèves, donc c'est dangereux.
Qu'est-ce que tu penses de la réforme
des retraites en France ?
Je suis partagé. Je suis partagé parce
que
moi je trouve scandaleux qu'on demande
aux gens de travailler depuis longtemps.
Euh on est
à une époque où le la productivité du
travail a qu'intuplé depuis 100 ans, un
truc comme ça. Et pourtant on travaille
toujours autant, ce qui me dépasse. Moi,
je suis très touché par des thématiques
comme la décroissance. J'ai pas
l'impression qu'on a besoin de produire
plus que ce qu'on produit et plutôt
qu'on a besoin de travailler moins, de
plus profiter de la vie. Donc quand on
parle de d'avancer la de de prolonger
euh le départ à la retraite, de baisser
la retraite, tout ça,
moi je je comprends pas. Après, quand on
parle d'un 42 régimes de retraite
différents, de nouveau, je comprends que
c'est ingérable depuis Paris de gérer
autant de trucs différents. C'est pas la
solution que je préconiserai, mais la
volonté de réforme de la France, bah
c'est bizarre, vous avez élu un mec qui
parlait de que faire des réformes et dès
qu'il essaie de faire une réforme, tout
le monde lui tombe dessus. Donc c'est un
peu
Attends, attends, attends, attends,
attends, attends. On a élu hein mec.
Ouais. 30 % des gens machin. Mais oui,
ça
c'est peut-être pas moins non, c'est
peut-être moins. Non.
Au 2è tour. Ouais. Si tu comptes ce
qu'on voter pour lui au premier tour,
c'est moi mais c'est alors de nouveau,
vous avez un scrit majoritaire à deux
tours et c'est un peu ça que ça ça donne
comme comme résultat au final, c'est que
ça donne le moins mauvais choix euh et
ça donne les pleins pouvoirs au moins
mauvais choix. Donc c'est ça ça revient
à ce que j'ai dit de décentraliser le
pouvoir, de le partager en plusieurs
parties, d'avoir une culture du
consensus, ça vous ferait peut-être pas
de mal par ça permettrait d'avancer par
petit pas donc plus lentement que ce qui
se fait maintenant mais avec moins de de
douleur sociale. Moi, la réforme des
retraites, bah déjà je suis humoriste,
je suis je suis pas sûr d'un jour avoir
une retraite parce que
je sais pas si tu as vu les spectacles
de Gade ou de Jamel de B mais à 45 ans,
c'est dur d'être encore drôle. Donc je
sais pas si je à l'âge de la retraite,
je ferai encore ce métier. Donc j'ai
vraiment de la peine à me projeter aussi
loin que ça.
Mais démographiquement, c'est sûr qu'on
peut pas continuer.
45 ans. C'est tu connais pas des vieux
humoristes américains ?
Oui, américains. Ouais. Ouais, bien sûr.
Américains, il y en a très il y en a
plein qui arrivent à durer.
Préféré
euh
qui est mon préféré ?
Je consomme de moins en moins d'humour,
ce qui est assez contradictoire, mais
j'ai de la peine à regarder des
spectacles de plus en plus parce que
j'ai l'impression de travailler puis
j'aime pas trop travailler. Je suis un
flemard. Mais qui est-ce que j'ai vu qui
est très bon récemment ? Moi j'aime bien
les anglais. J'aime bien j'aime bien
Ricky Dveis, j'aime bien Stuartley.
Parler de Ricky
qui est écossais. Je suis fan du roast
de ces émissions où il se balancent des
sales vanes à la gueule. Donc les mecs
qui officient dans ces émissions là, je
suis assez fan. Et les nanas aussi on
était très drôle. Sarah Silverman,
euh Natacha Lero desan comme ça. Moi
j'aime bien les vannes bah comme celles
que je fais contre les entreprise quoi.
Les gens qui font des vannes un peu
frontales comme ça, ça me plaît. Mais en
France, j'ai l'impression que c'est dès
que tu deviens méga connu dans l'humour,
tu fais un peu de télé, un peu de
cinéma, machin et après c'est difficile
de faire le 5e, le 6e, le 7e spectacle.
J'ai pas énormément d'exemples de gens
qui sont restés de façon constante.
Excellent.
Ça parle George Carline.
Ouais. Alors, j'ai c'est la génération
d'avant mais j'ai découvert un peu sur
YouTube et c'est fou de se dire que ce
mec était déjà très très pertinent à
l'époque et que ses trucs ont peu perdu
en pertinence quoi. Le le Seven words
you can't say on television, c'est assez
impressionnant parce que là pour le
coup, on parlait de censure. Bah là, la
censure existait puis le mec il est allé
frontal quoi. George Carlin et avant lui
c'était Denny Bruce. C'est deux mecs qui
ont qui ont abattu des frontières et et
on est tributeur de ce qu'ils ont réussi
à faire.
Il y a Bill Hick aussi que j'aime bien
notamment un passage sur le marketing.
Moi j'ai beaucoup de pe avec le
marketing et la pub et il a tout un
passage. Je crois que c'était à longur
d'air show les brasseurs de fumée.
Ouais voilà.
Puis il y a tout le monde qui à rigoler
là. Seriously puis il a tout un truc sur
le fait que les gens qui bosent en
marketing faut qu'il se tuent. Et ce qui
est évidemment pas ma position à moi
parce que mon collègue bosse dans le
marketing et je l'aime bien. Mais c'est
très drôle. Et
tu viens en colocation ?
Ouais. Tu vois ce que c'est la vie
d'artiste ?
Non, pour c'est presque par choix.
Enfin, c'était par choix à l'époque.
Puis maintenant c'est comme ça parce que
j'ai la flemme de déménager.
Question internet de bas. Que pense-t-il
de la prestation de Ricky Gervé au
Golden Glob 2020 ? Approuve-t-il la
démarche et pourquoi ? Ah oui, moi je
j'ai trouvé très drôle pour ceux qui ont
pas vu euh il a fait une entame de 7 8
minutes. C'est la 5e fois qu'il fait les
Golden Glob donc il est il est rompu à
l'exercice. Il a fait quelques vannes
sur Hollywood des très très drôles. Il a
fait une vanne sur l'âge de des meufs de
DiCaprio. Il a dit que le film était
tellement long qu'à la fin la date de
DiCaprio était trope pour lui. Il a fait
quelques vannes sur Jeffrey Epstein. Il
a fait vraiment un peu les sujets
brûlants et ce qui a beaucoup fait
parler et ce qui est pas ce qui m'a fait
le plus rien. Ça c'est vraiment ce début
là m'a beaucoup fait rien. Et après il a
fait une dénonciation du fait que les
acteurs réalisateurs, producteur
hollywoodiens sont majoritairement
démocrates de gauche et cetera mais il
travaillent pour Apple un peu Amazon
aussi maintenant et Google comme ça et
il a il a pointé cette hypocrisie du
doigt. Il a dit aux acteurs que gagnez
votre prix mais faites pas de discours
moralisata.
Et je trouve que ça c'est tout autant
une posture que l'inverse. C'est-à-dire
que Ricky Jvis qui dit aux acteurs de
parler pas de politique, c'est pour moi
tout aussi contradictoire que les
acteurs qui parlent de politique. Les
deux me vont, les deux me font rire,
enfin les les deux me conviennent. Je
vois pas pourquoi les acteurs devraient
arrêter de parler de politique. Tout
comme je trouve très drôle ce qu'a fait
Ricky Jvis parce que c'est du roast. Il
a les gens en face de lui, il les gagne
au début avec quelques vannes sur des
sujets assez larges et après il tape là
où ça fait mal. et et j'ai trouvé la
prestation très réussie, très maîtrisée.
Après sur internet, parfois il il me
il me convient, enfin c'est pas le mot,
mais je suis moins avec lui parce qu'il
a il a vraiment un truc un peu bah
presque un peu style Charlie Hebdo, il
provoque, il veut il veut avoir des
réactions et après il s'amuse des
réactions, il joue sur les réactions.
Enfin, il y a un truc qui est presque
autogénéré que je trouve un peu
artificiel sur internet. Oui, il va dire
le truc clivant provocateur et après il
va se moquer des gens qui réagissent à
sa provocation. Et ça, je trouve euh un
peu plus artificiel et un peu moins
intéressant que d'aller à un endroit et
dire aux gens euh de montrer du doigt
leur défaut. Ça, je l'ai trouvé très
très fort en Golden Glob.
Tu veux rajouter un mot sur la réforme
des retraites ?
Euh non, un mot sur la réforme des
retraites. Bah, j'espère que les grèves
vont se terminer parce que j'ai un
spectacle à faire et c'est moins 40 % de
spectacle.
Mon spectacle, il commence.
C'est où ?
Alors, c'est de
c'est combien ? Alors ouais trois bonnes
questions.
C'est 23 balles.
C'est 23 balles. Ouais. Alors c'est
marrant parce c'est 20 balles mais tu
payes 23. Donc je pense qu'il y a trois
qui est pour Fnac Bill Reduc ou je sais
pas quoi la plateforme de de ticketing
qui doit se faire de l'argent. C'est au
point virgule dans le Marais à Paris et
ça commence demain jusqu'au 31 janvier.
Combien de place ?
C'est 110. Donc on a 1600 places en
tout. On en a vendu 900. Et il y a des
les jours de grève c'est dur. Je crois
que jeudi donc après-demain mobilisation
générale bah il y a de la place. Donc si
vous avez rien à faire, je dis
je dis il y aura un gros dispositif de
l'État dans les rues. C'est
Ouais, venez à pied mais venez. Non,
donc moi égoïstement les grèves, ça
impacte mon petit spectacle. Après
depuis la Suisse, on regarde ça avec
beaucoup de recul mais de nouveau, comme
je te disais, ce que vous appliquez si
ça marche, on va l'avoir nous. Donc je
regarde quand même ça avec parce que la
la retraite par point augmenter l'âge de
retraite, ils ont essayé de le faire
chez nous pour les femmes parce que les
femmes c'est à 63, les hommes à 65 donc
on est un peu déjà plus vieux que vous.
Ils ont essayé de ramener les femmes à
65 et ça n'a pas passé pour l'instant.
Mais à mon avis, ça nous au nez et euh
et ouais, je regarde ça d'un œil assez
méfiant parce que j'aimerais plutôt
qu'on travaille moins que qu'on
travaille plus. Là, j'ai vu en Finlande,
la nouvelle première ministre propose la
semaine de 4 jours à 6 he de travail par
jour.
Ce serait incroyable si on arrive à
faire ça et c'est pour l'instant prouvé
que ça augmente la productivité et je
pense ça augmente le bonheur dans les
foyers et il y a moins de problèmes de
chômage parce que il y a plus de jobs du
coup si tout le monde travaille un peu à
temps partiel. J'ai l'impression que
c'est des solutions qui sont je sais pas
pourquoi elles sont pas plus explorées
que ça. Pourquoi on on les on les met
directement de côté ? En Suisse on a
voté sur le revenu de base universel. Je
sais qu'on en a beaucoup parlé avec les
gilets jaunes. Ça a été refusé à 78 %.
Euh c'est des trucs, je suis surpris
queon on essaye pas au moins
dans des domaines assez limités où on
fasse pas plus d'expérience là-dessus.
Je sais pas qui bloque ça, qui a peur de
ça, mais j'ai l'impression qu'il y a
quand même des trucs à explorer pour un
peu atténuer ce capitalisme parce que
j'ai l'impression que le capitalisme pur
et dur, on en atteint les limites. Là,
c'est quoi ta métaphore pour parler du
capitalisme ? un peu comme si on disait
qu'on avait une nouvelle voiture avec
une 7e vitesse.
Ah ouais ce que j'ai dit
on savait que le le mur était connecté
et que mais
je sais c'était un an donc là tu me
demandes de me rappeler de ce que j'ai
dit moi ce qui est un peu compliqué euh
non parce que c'était un forum bah c'est
le même forum où il y avait le mec de
Nesle mais on parlait des nouvelles
technologies tout ça comment aider
l'économie et moi j'avais plutôt
l'impression qu'il fallait qu'on freine
un peu la voiture.
Je disais que l'économiste une voiture
et puis là on nous explique qu'on fonce
droit dans le mur mais que le mur est
connecté donc on va savoir exactement où
on va frapper et c'est un peu
l'impression que j'ai c'est qu'on a de
plus en plus de technologies et cetera,
mais on réfléchit pas à comment la
technologie peut nous aider mais plutôt
comment vendre plus, comment faire plus
de fric avec et cetera et ça je trouve
un peu un peu flippant. Là, le un truc
qui m'a fait flipper, c'est au CES à Las
Vegas, le salon des d'électronique de
consommateur, Samsung qui développe des
humains de synthèse virtuelle et tu
regardes la vidéo et tu as l'impression
que c'est une vidéo et en fait cette
personne n'existe pas.
Le font aussi beaucoup.
Ouais, mais il le montre un peu moins.
Pour l'instant, il garde ça pour eux.
Mais le fait que bientôt on pourrait te
montrer une vidéo de quelqu'un, te faire
croire que c'est quelqu'un alors que
c'est totalement des images de synthèse,
moi ça me fait plus peur que rêver quoi.
Reconnaissance faciale, la surveillance
de masse, ça en parle en Suisse ou
on peut toujours on peut toujours
dénoncer son voisin pour folie et le
faire interner ou comment ça se passe ?
Alors folie, je crois pas. Est-ce que tu
peux faire ça par
Est-ce qu'on dénonce beaucoup en Suisse
?
C'est c'est pas un peu des gros
hypocrites planqués qui se dénoncent
entre eux comme ça ? époque,
on dit par exemple, il y a une citation,
un proverbe qui dit que en chaque Suisse
sommeille un flic
et même moi dans je viens du conton de
vau, on dit que chez le vaudo il est
réveillé. Donc c'est apparemment on est
les pires mais c'est vrai que si tu fais
du bruit après 22h, c'est pas impossible
que ton voisin appelle la police. Euh on
a des trucs aussi avec les
sacs poubelles taxés. Des fois, si tu
jettes pas les trucs au bon moment,
machin, on va on va venir te dénoncer.
Euh ça, je trouve ça plutôt bien
d'ailleurs parce que les
la dénonciation
alors la dénonciation non mais gérer les
déchets. Oui. Et
oui, je crois qu'on a un peu une culture
de la dénonciation. Alors, c'est moins
pire que dans les années 40 quand même.
On a un peu fait du chemin depuis
heureusement. Mais en fait, le Suisse
est pas frontal du tout. Donc, au lieu
de venir tenir les choses en face,
Suisse est fourbe. C'est ça
le Ouais.
Eve
peut-être peut-être lâche. C'est c'est
un adjectif que je m'appliquerai à
moi-même. C'est pour ça que je j'arrive
à l'appliquer à mes compatriotes, c'est
que on n' pas cette passion du de la
confrontation et la
franchise
Ouais, pas tellement. Non non, on va pas
on préfère faire les choses un peu par
la bande, par le côté et faire
comprendre les choses ou faire passer
les messages par d'autres. On a on a à
la fois au niveau politique et au niveau
personnel, je pense que la franchise
c'est pas le c'est pas le point fort du
pays quoi.
Euh tu parlais de Gadel Maly Copie
comique, c'est toi ?
Non mais à un moment donné on m'a
demandé, les gens pensaient que c'était
moi.
C'est une question d'internet hein.
Ah ouais ?
Non non non, c'est pas du tout moi parce
que bah comme j'ai dit, moi je regarde
très peu d'humour donc je serai
incapable d'être copy comique parce que
j'aime pas trop regarder les spectacles
des autres, les potes et tout ça, ça me
fait plaisir mais sinon je consomme très
peu et j'oublie les blagues. Bah on a vu
que j'oubliais les miennes donc celle
des autres, j'oublie encore plus. Donc
savoir que tel mec a fait telle blague
et tel mec l'a copié. Et moi, copie
comique, je suis un peu mitigé aussi
parce j'ai l'impression que dénoncer les
plagieurs, très bien. Le plagia,
personne aime ça dans l'humour. ma
génération euh qui ont qui ont appris un
peu des anglo-saxons, on était déjà
assez au courant que c'était négatif. La
génération d'avant, ils ont un peu plus
pris leurs aises, j'ai l'impression.
Mais maintenant, il y a un espèce de
climat de chasse au plagia qui est un
peu bizarre où dès que tu fais une
blague, les gens vont, au lieu de savoir
si elle est bonne ou pas, essayer de
chercher qui a déjà fait cette blague
avant, d'aller plonger dans les lindes
d'internet pour te ressortir l'humoriste
qui a fait la même blague puis tu là.
Oui, mais on est 15 fois plus
d'humoriste qu'avant. euh c'est
nettement plus facile de d'archiver les
blagues et d'y avoir accès. Donc il y a
beaucoup plus de coïncidence qu'avant et
le droit à la coïncidence a un peu
disparu. On est on est coupable de
plagia d'humoriste qu'on a jamais vu de
notre vie. Alors moi, j'ai jamais été
épinglé dans ces trucs mais ça m'arrive
d'avoir des commentaires de gens qui
disent "Tu as piqué cette blague à
machin ? Je sais pas qui est machin,
j'ai jamais vu son sketch et je suis
tout à fait conscient qu'il peut avoir
la même blague que moi. On est tous en
train de chercher les mêmes blagues sur
les mêmes sujets. Donc j'ai Ouais, les
limitations de copie comique me
paraissent assez évidentes dans le sens
où
pour moi les plus gros plagieurs et les
plus gros fautifs ont été épinglés.
C'est qui ?
Bah c'était Tomer Cisley. Pour moi,
Thomisley c'était vraiment assez
scandaleux. Michel Leb qui a piqué un
spectacle entier, Roland Magdane, des
mecs comme ça qui l'ont fait, qui l'ont
plus ou moins avoué. Gade pour moi, il
est un peu dans une zone grise où il l'a
fait beaucoup à une époque, un peu moins
par après, mais on l'a tellement passé
au peigne fin qu'on a retrouvé un peu
des trucs à gauche à droite. Pour moi,
c'était pas le pire, mais c'est très
bien que ce soit sorti. Mais continuer
d'aller chercher le petit humoriste qui
galère pour vendre des places de son
spectacle. On va on va chercher chacune
de ses blagues s'il y a pas un mec qui
l'a fait dans le Connecticut en 95. Je
vois pas bien l'intérêt et le problème
qu'il y a du coup et ça de nouveau c'est
l'égoïsme qui parle, c'est que par
exemple au Québec et aux États-Unis, les
humoristes français auxquels je suis
assimilé parce que pour eux c'est
compliqué de faire la différence entre
les Suisses, les Belges et les Français,
bah on est tous des plageurs parce qu'il
y en a trois qui ont été épinglés, trois
gros et quelquesuns des plus petits, bah
on est tous des plagieurs et on s'était
débarrassé de cette image très récemment
et ça a duré 6 mois puis après il y a
copie comique qui a débarqué donc ça
c'est un peu compliqué. Ouais.
Question question d'internet. Si
l'humour est une forme d'intelligence,
alors qui est le plus drôle ?
On dirait une blague Carambar. Mais
bah oui, moi
Carambar, la blague Carambar, ils
viennent de la marquer, c'est "J'espère
que les grèves vont s'arrêter parce que
j'ai un spectacle à faire".
Voilà,
ça c'est mon égoïsme à moi. Euh oui,
l'intelligence c'est une forme d'humour.
Ouais. En tout cas, les gens très
intelligents qui sont pas drôles, je
trouve que c'est un peu du gâchi quoi
parce que c'est tellement un vecteur
puissant pour faire passer un message
que je trouve bête de s'en priver. Par
exemple, une tradition américaine, il y
en a pas beaucoup qu'il faut imiter,
mais le le dîner des correspondants de
la Maison Blanche, moi j'étais chaque
année très impressionné par la faculté
du président
que ce soit Obama, Bush ou Clinton,
c'est les trois que j'ai connu de mon
vivant avant Trump, à faire des blagues
et à être drôle sur des sujets de
politique. Alors que je verrai pas ça en
France, je verrai pas ça en Suisse, mais
un mec intelligent qui utilise l'humour,
c'est très puissant. Et les gens
sérieux, on a de la peine à les écouter
en entier. C'est très puissant.
Bah, Colus ça l'était en tout cas.
Ouais,
c'est pour ça qu'il a peut-être fini, il
a glissé, il a peut-être pris un camion
par inadvertance comme ça.
C'est une
Est-ce que tu penses tu penses qu'il a
été buté ?
Bah c'est moi j'étais pas né hein. C'est
en quelle année ?
86. Non 87.
Ouais tiens, je suis 89. J'ai aucune
idée. Moi je j'ai l'impression que c'est
dur de garder un secret comme ça et que
ça serait sorti. Mais et j'ai pas
l'impression que c'était tant une menace
que ça qu'on le dit parce que quand on
quand on regarde vraiment sa campagne
présidentielle, bon moi j'ai vu j'ai vu
le film, j'ai lu un peu, j'ai pas vécu
ça en live évidemment euh mais il y a eu
des il y a eu des humoristes qui ont été
élus à des fonctions
à des fonctions politiques et puis
je bouche, c'est ça ?
Non mais Rean était un acteur, pas
comique mais un acteur. Il y a eu le
maire de Rikavic pendant très longtemps
qui était un humoriste. Je crois que le
président du Panama est un humoriste de
ce que j'ai vu, un très mauvais
humoriste mais un humoriste. Euh et il y
a eu il y en a eu qui ont été candidats
donc j'ai pas l'impression que c'était
un
un danger pour la démocratie. Bah
Coluche c'est marrant parce que Coluche
c'est quelqu'un qui plagiait beaucoup et
qui revendiquait. il disait qu'il
piquait les meilleures blagues de ses
potes et à l'époque ça passait très bien
par c'est lui qui les racontait les
mieux donc ses potes le laissait mais
euh oui, j'ai l'impression que c'est
quelqu'un qui a su utiliser l'humour
pour mettre le doigt sur des problèmes
de l'époque. Et les resto du cœur, c'est
quand même un héritage concret qui est
pas
des restos du cœur en Suisse.
Alors ça s'appelle pas le resto du cœur
mais il y a des trucs. Ouais, il y a un
truc qui s'appelle les repas du bonheur.
Ça c'est pendant les fêtes à Lausanne.
Je suis allé, il y a des trucs, il y a
des banques de nourriture, partage à
Genève, ça s'appelle. Euh il y a des
actions, c'est moins coordonné. Bah de
nouveau, c'est décentralisé, c'est un
peu chaque compant qui fait son truc,
mais ça existe. Il y a de la solidarité
en Suisse, il y a il y a un truc qui
s'appelle la maro d'usanne, les cartons
du cœur. Il y a il y a plein de trucs.
Ouais.
Alors, on vient de me signaler la
communauté Nigel Fake pour la Finlande
qui nous envoie un papier. Le passage de
la semaine de quel jours a-t-il vraiment
figuré ? Donc, on vous amène,
c'est peut-être une fake news.
Non, non. Ouais.
On en était à quoi là ? On parlait de
quoi ?
Remy Gaillard qui se présente à la
mairie de Montpellier, qu'est-ce que tu
en penses ?
Pourquoi pas ?
Qu'est-ce que tu penses de Remy Gaillard
?
Alors bah j'ai l'impression qu'il est
devenu un peu mono monosujet,
monomaniaque sur la défense du droit des
animaux. Si tu es maire d'une ville, il
y aura d'autres problématiques à gérer
aussi. Donc bah je sais pas qui est
maire de Montpeller à l'époque, je
connais pas la politique de Montpellier,
mais peut-être qu'il serait pas pire
d'avoir Remy Gaillard. Moi, j'aime bien
les mecs qui s'engagent. Après, la cause
des animaux, c'est pas du tout celle qui
me touche le plus. Je suis pas très
Voà. Toi, tu es plus fromage, viande
séchée ?
Je mange le fromage, je mange la viande
séchée. Ouais. J'essaie de diminuer ma
consommation de viande pour des raisons
écologique mais j'ai de la peine à je
sais pas, je suis je suis pas touché par
les animaux. La cruauté gratuite sur les
animaux me dérange, le système
agroalimentaire me dérange, mais l'homme
qui tue des animaux pour se nourrir,
j'ai j'ar ça arrive pas à moutrer. Mais
je juge pas les gens pour qui c'est le
cas et je trouve bien qu'ils s'engagent
pour leur truc, mais c'est pas le c'est
pas le combat qui me qui m'attire le
plus. Mais non, j'admire ce que fait
Réy. Je trouve que c'est ses méthodes
sont les mêmes qu'il a fait qu'il a
appliqué à d'autres domaines et que il
fait ça bien, il a des résultats. Bah
lui aussi il était dans Cy Comic puis
tout le monde s'en fout tant qu'il est
drôle. Enfin
pourquoi pas ? Moi je je trouverais bien
qu'il y a des profils plus divers en
politique. Je sais pas pourquoi c'est
toujours des mecs qui doivent enfin des
écoles des hautes écoles qui doivent
gouverner. J'ai l'impression que en
Suisse, ça c'est un des trucs qui est
qui est qui est assez cool, c'est qu'en
politique, on a beaucoup de politiciens
de milice, c'est-à-dire qui gardent un
job à côté. Alors, parfois c'est
cosmétique, c'est-à-dire que ils
s'engagent eux-mêmes dans leur job pour
leur fonction politique. Mais notre
présidente, elle est pianiste de
concert, c'est ça son métier. Euh, on a
un vigneron qui est au conseil fédéral,
on a des agriculteurs, enfin on a des
gens qui ont des autres métiers que
juste juriste, avocat ou fonctionnaires.
Donc ça c'est
connecté avec la vraie vie
ou il l'était à un moment donné. En tout
cas, après c'est facile
chefs d'entreprise,
c'est facile d'être déconnecté, mais il
y a moins un cursus
au fonctionnaires politique machin. Donc
des mecs comme Ry Gaillard qui peuvent
secouer un peu cette fourmilière là et
encore plus au niveau municipal
communal, c'est-à-dire que lui il est de
Montpellier, il a toujours vécu à
Montpellier, il connait Montpellier. Ben
je trouve très bien qu'il s'engage en
politique à Montpellier. Ouais.
Tu vois s'engager en politique
nationale. Remy Gaillard, président.
Bah écoute, il a il a réussi des des
trucs assez incroyables, il pourrait
réussir ça. Après, je sais pas si ce
serait bien ou pas. De nouveau, on
connait son engagement pour les animaux.
On sait pas, on connaît pas ses
positions sur beaucoup d'autres choses.
Question internet, est-ce que tu as eu
des problèmes avec les câaux ?
Non. Euh,
est-ce que tu es un ami imaginaire ?
Non. Alors, je suis à T moi. Euh non,
j'ai pas eu de problème avec les cataux
dont je puisse me souvenir. Alors,
peut-être un message par-ci parlà, mais
j'ai pas eu d'action coordonnée. Mais en
Suisse, la la religion catholique est
moins puissante. Il y a certains
compants où ils sont encore très
présents. Le valet notamment est très
catholique, Fribourg est très catholique
mais
sinon non, il y a il y a pas la manif
pour tous des trucs comme ça. Bon, on n
pas le mariage homosexuel en Suisse, on
a que le le partenariat enregistré.
C'est c'est euh c'est quoi un
partenariat enregistré ?
Un pax.
Ça, on a le pax pour les personnes du
même sexe et je crois que l'adoption
pour les personnes du même sexe c'est
compliqué mais
sinon
on n pas cette frange catholique dure
Frigide Bargeot la manif pour tous ça.
J'ai pas l'impression que c'est un
courant de pensée qui est très
représenté en Suisse. Mais on est un
pays plutôt protestant de façon
majoritaire. luthérien,
calviniste à Genève peut-être luthérien
du côté germanophone. Ouais.
Ah, il y a beaucoup de questions sur
copie comique, hein. On va pas pouvoir
toutes les prendre les gars. Euh et les
filles euh euh
mais je crois que copie comique a un
truc que on surestime un peu son impact.
C'estàdire que dans l'autre soit
parisien peut-être dans le milieu de
l'humour, ça a fait beaucoup réagir sur
internet, les réseaux, ça fait beaucoup
réagir. Il y a des gens qui ont
totalement effacé Gadel Mala en disant
que c'était plus un humoriste qui
achèteraiit plus jamais de billet. et sa
tournée se vend super bien. Donc le
grand public en fait s'en fout et c'est
ça qu'on réalise, c'est que ça fait
beaucoup parler dans les médias et au
final les mecs c'est toujours ceux qui
vont le plus de place quoi.
Question : que pensent-t-il de la main
mise des assurances maladies sur la
politique suisse ? Ça,
ouais, ça c'est problématique. En
Suisse, on a des assurances maladies qui
ont beaucoup de pouvoir, qui achètent
des politiciens, c'est-à-dire qu'il les
payent pour des groupes de réflexion et
du coup, ils reçoivent beaucoup
d'argent. un de nos un de nos
conseillers fédraux. Donc les
conseillers fédéraux, c'est les c'est
les sept qui sont les ministres,
c'est-à-dire que c'est le cabinet
exécutif de la Suisse et c'est chaque
fois un des SEP qui est président. Et
donc un des SEP, il était président de
l'association des assurances maladies
avant d'être élu au gouvernement. Euh
donc, ils ont beaucoup de pouvoir. Euh
le système médical suisse, c'est un des
plus performants au monde et un des plus
chers.
Les factures de d'assurance maladie,
c'est par moi, je paye 5000 balles par
an, donc genre 4000 €. Donc c'est un
salaire. Et euh
on a les médicaments les plus chers au
monde alors que c'est quand même nous
qui les fabriquons la plupart. Donc il y
a bah Novis, Roche, tout ça c'est chez
nous et pourtant ils sont vendus plus
chers chez nous qu'ailleurs. Donc il y a
vraiment il y a des aberrations, il y a
des trucs assez assez étonnants en
Suisse avec la santé.
Alors c'est là question internet encore,
il y a beaucoup de questions internet.
Ça c'est un peu une boutade. C'est vrai
que quand un dictateur meurt, une banque
suisse ferme.
Euh bah en tout cas
Ouais ouais. Bah écoute, en tout cas, on
a beaucoup beaucoup de dictateurs qui
ont de l'argent chez nous. Il y a un
compte Twitter qui est très cool qui
s'appelle Geneva Dictator Alert, je
crois. Oui. Perfect Accent.
Yes. J'ai vécu un peu
où ça ?
Euh Londres, Michigan et New York. Et
c'est un compte qui
Milinois. Milinois, c'est bien.
Michigan. Ah pardon Michigan juste à
côté. Ouais, il y a un compte qui
répertorie les arrivées et les départs
de Jet qui appartiennent à des
gouvernements d'autocrates. Donc tu
Ouais, je crois que c'est GVA dictator
alerte. Je le dis avec l'accent français
comme ça on arrive à me suivre. Euh
comme Syerview.
Sinker. Ouais, ça me fait rire à chaque
fois. Vous avez appelé votre chaîne d'un
nom que vous arrivez pas à prononcer.
Mais si,
on arrive à le prononcer mais on
revendique notre action notre accent
français. On le revendique. Tu sais
pourquoi c'est Rafarin ?
Non. Non. Ça si tu avais dit Chiraak,
you come back in my plane, j'aurais dit
d'accord, me parle pas de lui. Non, tu
sais pourquoi ? Parce que l'accent
français dans le monde, tu dis tout le
temps dans tes spectacles que tu as du
mal à péchot.
Et ben mon pote, tu prends l'accent
français, regarde-elui à côté avec sa sa
tête, il arrive quand même à attraper
des suisses. Donc n'hésite pas l'accent
français.
Mais tu sais quoi ? C'est marant que tu
dises ça parce quand j'étais en échange
aux États-Unis euh dans le Michigan donc
j'étais avec plusieurs potes suisses
francophones qui eux avaient l'accent
français
Chicago
Michigan c'est à côté de des enfin c'est
la capitale c'est enfin c'est pas la
capitale mais la plus grande ville c'est
D3 j'étais à 1 heure de D3 en quelle
année
comment ça s'est passé là-bas avec la
crise financière tu as eu une perception
de ce qui se passait dans la rue
non sur un campus universitaire tu es un
peu tu es coupé du mond
tu voyais pas des étudiants avec des
dents manquantes, de l'air
Non, parce que bah le l'écollage, il
était 20000 dollars par an. Donc ilétait
pas dans cette école. Mais par contre,
je suis allé à D3
pour voir un match de hockey. Et là,
c'était flippant parce que la ville de
D3
avait la même population. Donc, on est
en 2010 qu'en 1920, c'est-à-dire que
c'est une ville fantôme et ils étaient
obligés de rassembler des gens dans des
quartiers parce que ils étaient
tellement éparpiés dans la ville que
c'était plus possible pour les écoles,
pour les pompiers, pour les hôpitaux.
Donc, il devait dire aux gens, bah on
abandonne ce quartierl puis vous
déménagez là. Donc tu avais des
quartiers fantômes. Le centre-ville
c'était quasi que des boutiques avec des
parois de bois comme pendant le G8 quoi.
C'était c'était assez flippant. Et des
trois Inner City donc Intramuros, c'est
je crois 92 % afhro-américain
euh parce qu'ils sont tous dans les dans
les bons lieux les blancs. Et quand tu
allais voir le match d'quet avait 20000
blancs au milieu de TR donc c'était
assez surréaliste comme expérience mais
non sur le campus universitaire sortait
pas du tout. Mais par contre mes potes
avec l'accent français avaient plus de
succès que moi et du coup je me suis dit
que c'était ça. Mais est-ce que je me
leurais pour pour ne pas avoir la
réalité en face parce qu'il y a
peut-être d'autres problèmes que mon
accent mais en tout cas j'ai
Qu'est-ce que tu dis ? Je je sais pas,
j'étais pas dans la tête de ces dames
mais en tout cas oui, je me suis rendu
compte du pouvoir d'attraction de
l'accent français et je me suis demandé
si j'allais pas faire semblant de
l'avir. Mais après,
mon éthique a pris le dessus où je me
disais que commencer par mentir sur ton
accent, c'était pas partir sur les
bonnes bases. Et puis le lendemain de
commencer à parler anglais normalement,
une fois que tu l'as péchaud, je pense
que ça aurait été compliqué.
Parler anglais normalement, c'est une
chose que les français ne peuvent pas
faire.
Je sais, je je m'en suis bien rendu
compte. C'est quand même l'accent
officiel pour piloter un avion de chasse
hein.
Nous, on a pas ce problème. Nos avions
de chasse, on on a eu un problème, c'est
ça ?
Al le gripon, on l'a pas acheté. Ouais.
Ah oui,
on a voté contre. Là, ils vont devoir en
racheter. Mais on avait eu une énorme
polémique parce qu'il y a eu un vol
détourné
qui a passé sur le territoire aérien
suisse et nos avions de chasse n'étaient
pas opérationnels en dehors des heures
de bureau. Donc, il était genre 18h et
on a dû appeler je crois le l'armée de
l'air italienne parce que les pilotes
suisses étaient rentrés à la maison.
Bah, il y a des heures pour travailler
hein.
Bah voilà, si vous voulez attaquer la
Suisse, il suffit d'attendre 17h 17h30
si peut-être ils font des heures sup
puis après c'est bon.
Euh, on arrive bientôt à la fin, on va
on va encore prendre quelques questions,
donc n'hésitez pas. Euh donc les
États-Unis, c'est bon. Trump, avec ton
expérience aux États-Unis, tu en penses
quoi ?
Bah, j'ai j'ai de la peine des fois à
réaliser encore que c'est vrai quoi. Il
y a un truc un peu tellement dystopique
de ce mec. Toi
tu étais en France et tu avais dit que
Clinton arriverait avec 98 %. J'étais
enfin j'habitais en Suisse à l'époque
mais j'avais fait une chronique à
quotidien le soir de l'élection donc à
19h alors que tu
as vu Yan Bartz s'effondré ?
Alors je suis rentré dormir, j'ai pas
fait la nuit avec lui. Mais oui, j'ai
dit un truc 90 % de chance je crois
alors que je voulais dire 99 donc j'ai
j'avais déjà un peu modéré mes attentes.
Mais comme tout le monde, je suis je
suis tombé dedans quoi.
Comment t'explique ça ? pas comme tout
le monde hein parce que
non il après coup on trouve toujours les
gens qui avaient raison mais sur le
moment il y avait vraiment un group
think qui disait que c'était Clinton à
coup sû
je sais pas moi j'étais allé à Las Vegas
pour le 3ème débat Clinton Trump pour un
magazine dans quel hôtel
je sais plus Mirage
avec les les Tigres blancs c'est ça et
les Sigfrieden and Roy
ah mais ils sont plus parce qu'il y en a
un qui a failli se faire bouffer il y a
il y a 10 ans. Il est qui ? C'est un
légume je crois. Je sais plus si Friday
mais il y en a un qui s'est fait aper la
tête par un tigre et du coup ils sont
ils sont à la retraite mais ils sont
multi multi multimillionnaires. Euh non
mais je suis pas allé voir si je suis
allé voir le circle du soleil mais je me
suis endormi.
Remplacé par Cine Dion, c'est ça ? Non,
ça ça va en plus mais j'étais allé voir
le débat et puis j'avais fait des une
chronique sur le débat et
c'était marrant parce que tu avais
vraiment l'impression que tu avais une
politicienne politicienne puis un homme
de spectacle quoi. C'était un espèce de
clash de de style et de d'objectif quoi.
Ils s'en foutaiit d'avoir un programme
ou quoi que ce soit. C'était il fallait
trouver la punch, avoir l'air d'avoir
raison et cetera. Et je sais pas comment
j'explique ça, mais je pense que c'est
la perception qu'on a des États-Unis
depuis ici, c'est c'est New York, c'est
Los Angeles, c'est un peu les métropoles
des côtes et c'est pas eux qui on voté
quoi. enfin en terme de population euh
c'est vraiment le centre des États-Unis
qui a voté Trump et et je pense qu'on a
peut-être sous-estimer le système
bipartite qui fait que
tu votes beaucoup bah un peu comme au
deuxème tour en France, tu votes
beaucoup contre quelqu'un plutôt que
pour l'autre et il y a beaucoup de gens
qui étaient contre Clinton et je pense
qu'ils ont sous-estimé à quel point
l'opinion publique était contre Clinton
et ils se disaient bon bah Trump ça peut
pas être pire que Clinton alors que vu
d'Europe tout le monde était contre
Trump plutôt que pour Clinton donc je
pense c'est ce que en tout cas moi C'est
ce calcul là
le journaliste. Comment t'explique qu'il
se fasse intoxiquer ? C'est quoi ? C'est
de la déconnexion ? C'est parce qu'il
veut faire passer ses valeurs ? C'est
parce que quoi ? Il a pas fait son son
travail d'analyste ?
Ah, il travaille avec des sondages euh
sondages
alors que les sondages sont imparfaits
et que en plus
les journalistes sont pas forcément très
bons en statistique. Donc ils
comprennent pas ce que c'est qu'une
marge d'erreur, une variance, un
écart-type, des trucs comme ça. Donc
c'est
c'est le comptable qui parle là.
C'est le B ouais, j'ai fait HC moi dans
une autre vie. Mais je pense c'est ça.
Donc s'il voit Clinton avec un écart
type de de 3 %, il va se dire "Bah c'est
bon, ça veut dire que au pire elle a 51
% donc on peut annoncer que c'est elle."
Et moi je me mets dedans hein, je suis
tombé dedans aussi. Et oui, il y a un
truc où tous les journalistes sont
ensemble. Les journalistes sont pas
représentatifs de la couche de
population américaine mal éduquée euh
qui souffre de la déportation des
emplois au tiers monde et cetera. Et
donc les journalistes sont des gens qui
ont fait des études qui vivent plutôt
bien et qui analysent le monde avec leur
prisme à eux. Donc je pense que c'est un
peu ça qui se passe en France. Non,
je sais pas, je connais pas assez bien
ce qui se passe ici pour vraiment donner
ce truc là. J'ai l'impression qu'il y a
beaucoup de journalistes qui sont un peu
à Paris. Ouais. Qui sont dans les redac
parisiennes. Mais de nouveau c'est je
comprends pas pourquoi en région il y a
pas il se passe pas plus de trucs. On
arrive à la fin de notre interview.
Est-ce que tu vois des sujets à aborder
que tu aimerais aborder avec nous ?
Non non, moi je suis venu en mode
flemmeardise, ils vont me poser des
questions puis du coup j'aurais pas pas
réfléchir.
Alors on va te poser une question.
Est-ce que tu as trois bouquins à
conseiller à notre à notre communauté ?
Ah moi c'est horrible parce que
je sais pas lire. Euh j'arrive pas à
Toi, tu as fait HC, hein.
Ouais.
Tu veux pas nous parler un peu de HC que
en Suisse ça se passe bien ? C'est c'est
comment ?
Bah HC Lausanne, c'était assez
particulier. Euh c'est marrant parce
qu'il y a pas mal de gens qui ont fini
ailleurs. HC Lausanne, tu as des des
profils aussi différents que genre
Seblat de la FIFA, il l'a fait HC à
l'époque. Gaspar Prou a fait HC à
Lausanne. On a aussi des rappeurs et des
mecs comme ça. Donc c'est assez c'est
pas comme à Paris où c'est à Jon Josas
où c'est un peu très élitiste, c'est
très fourtout. C'est-à-dire que c'est un
peu le truc par élimination quand tu
veux bosser un peu dans l'économie. Donc
moi je me souviens qu'il y avait il y a
beaucoup de français beaucoup de
français qui avaient raté une prépa ou
qui était pas entré à CHC ou à Lesc ou
je sais pas une de vos écoles qui venait
chez nous.
Ouais, il venait à chac Lausanne et
plein de profils différents. Donc il y
avait des mecs très capitalistes. Il y
avait des mecs avec des kéfiers, des
trucs chegevara qui voulaient changer,
faire péter le système et puis tu avais
plein de types paumés un peu comme moi
qui faisaient ça par défaut parce qu'ils
savaient pas quoi faire de leur vie.
Donc j'ai un assez bon souvenir des
études mais dès que j'ai voulu choisir
un métier, j'is qu'il y avait aucun des
métiers qui qui m'intéressait et puis
c'est pour ça que j'ai essayé celui-là.
Mais les bouquins, je suis Ouais, je
suis un peu emprunté. Euh
euh j'ai lu j'ai un mec qui me fait
beaucoup rire euh qui est un Australien
qui s'appelle David Roth.
Non, faudrait David Roth. Euh
c'est un c'est un troll. C'est un mec
qui qui envoie des emails chiants à tout
le monde et puis qui essaie de rendre
fou les gens. Ça c'est très drôle. Il a
sorti 5 six bouquins. Le dernier qu' a
sorti, c'est le dernier que j'ai lu
qui s'appelle
qui s'appelle c'est une super longue
phrase. Le premier s'appelle "The
internet is a playground".
Internet est une place de jeu et après
vous trouverez les autres. Après c'est
toujours des phrases de trois lignes.
Donc il y en a un qui s'appelle "Cache
le médicament dans le pâté". Comme ça le
chien le verra pas.
C'est que des trucs un peu comme ça.
Mais ça ça me fait rire.
Tu as fait une blague avec ça ? Non.
Oui, mais te dire laquelle c'est, je
sais plus.
Oui. Oui. J'ai fait une blague où je
disais que c'était ça, un truc politique
mais je sais plus lequel.
Un troisème bouquin.
Un troisème bouquin qui m'a fait rire.
Tu es gentil de dire un troisème parce
j'en ai j'en ai proposé qu'un pour
l'instant. Donc tu me tu me fais déjà
cadeau d'un seul.
Non, il y a un truc, c'est pas un
bouquin, mais c'est une recommandation
peut-être qui va plaire aux gens qui
regardent Thinker Viiew, c'est moi je
fais beaucoup des des quiz général sur
internet parce que je suis un peu
asperger donc j'aime bien les listes.
C'est quoi un peu Asperger ? Tu arrives
pas à regarder les gens dans les yeux ?
Qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
J'arrive un peu mais pas tout le temps.
Ça dépend un peu des circonstances. J'ai
de la peine avec les inconnus, j'ai de
la peine avec la foule. physique,
ça ça va. Ça ça c'est pour ça j'ai
certains ma psy me dit que je suis pas
asperger donc j'ai j'ai certains
symptômes d'autres pas mais genre j'aime
bien. Tu fais une thérapie en ce moment.
Ouais.
À cause de qui ?
De moi.
Très bon réponse.
Euh
j'aime bien les listes, j'aime bien les
infos, le sport. Je suis fou de sport et
de statistiques sportives et d'histoire
du sport machin. Et donc j'ai un site
sur lequel je vais beaucoup deux sites
même spork.com et hugequiz.com.
Il y a pas que le sport, il y a toutes
les catégories pu c'est genre tu dois
lister les 500 plus grandes villes des
États-Unis pu ça je peux faire pendant
des heures. Donc ça c'est à la place de
lire des bouquins, je passe ma journée à
apprendre qu'est-ce que j'ai appris
récemment ? J'ai appris les 100 comptes
Instagram qui ont le plus de followers.
Ça sert à rien mais c'est je sais pas,
j'engrange de l'information puis j'aime
bien. C'est
lequel ? Bah le premier c'est Instagram,
2è c'est Cristiano Ronaldo, puis après
tu as les Kardashian et tout ça, puis
après tu as beaucoup d'indiens, tu as
beaucoup de Brésiliens. Enfin ça c'est
intéressant de voir euh
l'image que ça donne de notre de notre
monde. Et euh donc ça c'est des sites où
je perds beaucoup de temps à faire des
quiz. Spork et hugqueiz.com.
Tu aurais envie de vivre en Chine ?
Non,
même pas de visiter pour le moment. Ça
m'attire pas tellement. Bah moi quand
j'ai fait HC, c'était un peu le
Eldorado.
Bah comme c'était la crise de sub prime
et que la Chine s'en sortait plutôt
bien, il y avait plein de gens qui
voulaient apprendre le Chinois qui
regardait pour faire des échanges à
Shanghaiï à Hong Kong et cetera et moi
pas du tout. Bah tu vois, je suis allé
dans le Michigan mais non ça m'attire
pas tellement. Etth et on a dans
l'économie, on soulligne souvent la peur
que la Chine vienne et rafle tout et
nous pique tous nos boulots. Et j'ai
l'impression que dans l'humour, on a
peut-être un peu moins de risque de ce
côté-là.
Je sais pas, je connais pas l'humour
chinois mais j'ai pas l'impression que
bon l'humour suisse non plus c'est pas
notre point fort mais j'ai pas
l'impression que l'humour chinois c'est
le péril jaune comme dans d'autres
domaines quoi.
Est-ce que tu as un conseil pour les
jeunes générations ?
Non parce que j'ai j'ai encore
l'illusion de penser que j'en fais
partie. Euh
30 piges
justement ouais mais c'est c'est le
déniis, tu vois. C'est la partie où tu
Non, il y a souvent des jeunes qui
m'écrivent parce qu'ils veulent se
lancer dans l'humour tout ça.
C'est quoi des jeunes ?
bah de plus en plus jeune, genre 14 15
16 17 comme ça qui sont au moment où ils
doivent choisir une
filière et
j'ai l'impression qu'il y a un piège
à éviter, c'est que il y a beaucoup de
gens qui choisissent cette filière pour
être connu ou pour être dans les trucs
où tu es connu ou pour avoir beaucoup de
gens sur YouTube machin. Etth et ça
c'est pas la c'est pas la bonne filière.
Si tu veux être connu, il faut être
influenceur. Enfin, faut faire un truc
où tu as pas besoin de
Est-ce que tu as un avis sur les
influenceurs ? Est-ce que tu as des
chaînes YouTube à conseiller ?
Ouais. qui crèvent. Euh non, j'ai
vraiment de la peine avec ça. C'est
vraiment ça me rend fou. Ouais. cette
espèce d'hypocrisie de faire croire que
toi tu utilises un truc alors qu'on t'a
payé pour enfin la pub déjà j'ai de la
peine mais au moins j'ai l'impression
que les trucs sont clairs. Tu sais que
George Cloney il a touché de l'argent
pour boire un espresso que c'est pas lui
qui dessine tandis que l'influenceur il
va te faire croire que lui tout seul
dans son salon il a ça alors qu'on lui a
filé du fric pour ça ça me rend fou
cette espèce de de lavage de cerveau.
Puis ces hommes et femmes sandwich qui
sont tout contents de de prendre de
l'argent de marque en échange de leur de
leur authenticité et puis de leur leur
éthique. Ça, j'ai vraimentoup beaucoup
de peine. Mais j'ai l'impression que si
tu veux être connu, c'est quand même le
plus simple, la téléréalité et
influenceur. Parce qu'h humoriste, on
doit quand même produire du contenu.
Donc les mecs qui et les nanas qui me
demandent comment être humoriste, ben
écrit écrit écrit. Euh et
ça c'est ton conseil ?
Ouais. Écris, développe un propos,
apprends à
tu peux écrire si tu ne lis pas.
Bah, je lis beaucoup mais que des
articles que des que des trucs courts
quoi, des magazines, des journaux,
internet, des Twitter, des statuts, des
machins, mais j'arrive pas à lire des
bouquins. Pas
un auteur qui t'a vraiment plus marqué
qu'un autre ?
J'ai lu quasi tout Paul Oster que
j'aimais bien. Euh ça ça me plaisait
bien. Euh non, j'ai eu des périodes BBD,
j'ai lu parfois et j'ai trouvé pas mal.
Euh
mais non, j'ai vraiment cette lacune
dans ma culture et j'ai j'ai lu jusqu'à
mes 15 16 ans et après j'ai totalement
lâché et c'est chaque année un peu ma
résolution pas officielle parce j'en
prends pas tellement.
Espagnol j'espère.
J'ai lu à l'école Ouais mais non ça m'a
pas touché plus que ça.
Euh le
je te relance sur le conseil pour le je
génération. Écrire écrire écrire. Bah si
tu veux faire un métier où tu dois
proposer un contenu aux gens, ouais,
entraîne-toi à savoir quoi dire parce
que c'est euh j'ai l'impression qu'on
peut apprendre à être drôle euh jusqu'à
un certain stade ou en tout cas à polir
ton propos et cetera, mais développer un
fond et
développer des choses à dire, ça prend
plus de temps. Donc intéressez-vous au
monde autour de vous. Et ça, j'ai
l'impression que la jeune génération le
fait mieux que ma génération.
C'est-à-dire que les jeunes de 15 ans
qui sont dans la rue, je trouve ça très
cool parce que ma génération, on a un
peu délaissé ça tellement tout allait
bien quand on était jeune que
moi, j'entends souvent des gens de mon
âge dire "Ah la politique, je m'en fous
et pour moi tu devrais pas pouvoir t'en
foutre." Ça devrait pas être une option.
Donc ça je les félicite les jeunes et je
trouve c'est intéressez-vous au moins
qui vous entoure et développez des avis
et apprenez à les exprimer par ça en
France vous êtes meilleur qu'en Suisse
et aux États-Unis sont nettement
meilleurs que nous de savoir comment
s'exprimer et d'oser donner son avis.
Euh ça on a encore un peu de peine ici
j'ai l'impression. Une
blague qui viennent de nous faire un
suisse de gauche c'est un français
Thomas.
Vous êtes de moins en moins de gauche
quand même ici hein j'ai l'impression.
Et nous de plus en plus donc on va se
retrouver au milieu.
Ouais ouais méfiez-vous vous allez faire
en marche.
Ouais ils ont essayé mais ça n'a pas
fonctionné.
Qui c'est qui a essayé ?
Un mec qui s'appelle Eric Stofer à
Genève qui une espèce de grande gueule.
Il a fait Genève en marche et il était
antifrontalier. Ce qui assez
contradictoire.
Est-ce que tu veux rajouter un mot ?
Je savais que tu allais demander ça et
j'ai oublié de réfléchir à ce que
j'allais dire.
Thomas Visel, merci.
[Musique]